two hello everybody it is Wednesday a
beautiful day out here in it Los Angeles
not a cloud Insight
frankly not a cloud Insight
actually as LA's hottest news uh weather
reporter I'm going to bring you guys the
full 7-day forecast out here right
outside it's looking about 84° 7%
humidity 1 mph wind that's a light
Breeze yes some clouds be rolling in on
Friday but you know it stays beautiful
out here in La every
day and I'm Ethan Klein once again for
your weekly
forecast how about that weather
huh that's right that's right that's
right that is right fun good times
welcome everybody though for real it is
off the off the rails although we don't
have a super off the rails episode today
maybe we need to mix it up cuz we're
going to be cutting into Jade stone
perhaps if we could lose a finger or two
we can go off the
rails we're doing Jade gambling today
for real we have uh
yeah stick your fer it's pretty exciting
and I know there's a lot of Jed heads
Jade heads Jade
n in in the audience and so we have
three lovely um ecologist SL gem
enthusiast
who have come today uh with tons of
harvested stones that they collected
themselves in the bowels of the Earth's
very uh in bowels bowels of the bowels
wow to keep the earth clean and do what
Ze do and we are going to be cutting
into it we are going to be gambling on
them I'm very very excited and there
could be real Treasures in these rocks
we might one of us might strike it rich
today that's very
exciting
um we've also
got all kinds of fun stuff to talk
about and uh we're going to do all that
stuff here today and more on the H3
podcast thank you so how yeah also
not thank you no sponsors today it's a
sad day it's a sad month to be
AG
podcast but on the plus side we have so
many gracious members that support the
show and I thank you all so much baby is
sad and got really sad I'm so
sad but uh the good news is there's a
new Teddy fresh drop coming out on the
second just show you guys a preview here
I got to say in office everyone was
having trouble deciding on what they
want because everyone was a big fan of
this drop dude this drops thank you for
saying that a this drop goes crazy
doesn't it dude it's so sick all the
outer wear is so nice oh that's
dope look at all this stuff it's getting
out of control the quality is getting
out of control you guys it's not right
it's not fair to other fashion brands
someone's I can't control I just can't
control my goo
anymore I like this
model our models lately have been really
cool I like this
guy love him so hot right now okay D
this guy's making all the clothes look
yo that beanie she okay hold on that
shirt
though wow dude what what are you guys
cooking up back there I don't even know
what are you guys what are you guys even
doing back there dress do we love this
that dress do we love this wait a second
do you want this Olive I think that
maybe that might be a winner tell L you
you got that
mhm thank you L whatever you guys want
though oh this puffer jacket it's crazy
wait what about these gloves teddy bear
gloves the poer fingerless gloves are so
in right now they are love I mean what
do you do gloves with finger
covers they're just kind of unruly it's
outdated technology it's like thank you
AB go on we need them for our phones we
need to access our fingers though that's
what I'm say you know it it's just time
to move on from fingered gloves mhm you
know it's a 21st thing on that Vibe way
ahead of the time who's that fingerless
gloves who homeless people homeless
people what I was going to say and why
is that love cuz they can't afford ones
with yeah love why that's right you just
call AB love why don't you get a house
wait why did you just accuse love of
being
homeless said anything about love now
sorry sorry sorry let me just let me
just let me just back up you said
homeless people know about fingerless
gloves right right oh you call me love
yeah but then you said love knows about
it or did you not say that no okay I
miss I got a house right here dude that
was a
mess I'm homeless true yeah man this all
I want that Bonn it bad
also cly yeah wow wa oh adorable
wait that's awesome what who Nelly wo
Nelly so here it is there's all kinds of
really cool stuff popping oh this is
interesting too there it is there it so
there it is shot so bad thank you
everybody what the hell um how was
everybody's you know Halloween we had
frankly
um we had a really you know heartfelt
conversation about it on Monday and Zach
confided and all of us and some of y'all
in the chat as well that Halloween has
lost its magic so my question to you
guys is how was your
Halloween Zach let's start with you uh
terrible terrible yeah was terrible yeah
I mean it was I stayed home you know it
was a work night you know so you know
bed early and you know just another day
of the week so it wasn't worse than
other days
no it just I feel like the spirit's gone
like I was asking my family can you play
sad music for yourself uh uh I I suppose
I can yeah yeah just go ahead no it's
just like existential dread you
know existential dread from not being I
mean getting older dude I mean what do
you figure Zach was he was a child when
he came to us that's true and now he
goes to bed early on Halloween yeah I
mean went to dinner and bed you
know that's it dinner's Vibes though
where'd you go for dinner I cooked oh
you cooked so you didn't go out no no no
no what did you make uh I made a chicken
thighs and some vodka sauce oh that
sounds good yeah it was pretty good um
did you make the vodka sauce no no no
Trader Joe got it um but yeah I I feel
like it's gone like I was asking my
friends I'm like did you get any
trick-or-treaters at your house or
anything like no nothing so do we all
remember when we were kids that like
everywhere everyone was
trick-or-treating was it just like that
or are we misremembering that was my
that was my that was my experience too
in my memory it was just like the whole
world was outside mhm yeah yeah
beautiful decoration everywhere world
was outside like there there's a spot in
the valley I used to go to drive around
with my parents and friend it's gone but
did you go back to that go there I went
back a couple years ago and it it's it's
gone since Co it's just gone wow yeah
well that breaks my heart you know I
went with the boys down to uh I don't
know the exact neighborhood it's in
Korea Town but we've been going here
every every year for the past couple
years my brother lives there mhm and it
is nuts I have never seen so many
trick-or cheaters in my life dude the
whole I'm talking like 3x3 mile radius
like shoulder toosh shoulder that's the
neighborhood I grew up in oh yeah
somebody told me oh that neighborhood's
not it's really cool yeah I love I
literally love it over there and
you're do your does your family partake
in the Halloween Madness oh yeah my mom
is obsessed it's almost like HOA there
you have too oh yeah you're you're a bad
person if you don't it's amazing how
many of these it's like a it's
definitely a nice neighborhood and you
can tell that the people who live there
take the responsibility seriously yeah
the only times we haven't are because um
our new dog is uh a barker so we need to
figure that out but yeah no my parents
love stupid bad were you there yesterday
or no I wasn't there yeah no I wasn't
there either well I yeah you could have
been yeah you could have been you got
the was too depressed kind of problem
you would have been you would have woken
up you I'm going to go Tri no but just
to then what do you want I want Spirit
back I want to be a kid again damn it I
want to be a kid again damn it well you
better stop complaining cuz
you're like 20 how old are you 26 yeah
just dude stop stop like you ever see
those memes on like Instagram reals
where it's like oh was all a dream and
you're back in like 2016 like I want
that dude Zach you got to get
your together you're 26 I'm trying
to man I'm 38 bro yeah I'm trying to I
can't I can't grab getting older and I
want to be a kid again you are a kid
again what is it that a kid does a kid
is like that you can't do when you're
young you're like you're so ignorant you
like you don't like you don't have any
responsibilities you can just like like
off right it's just like everything
you're getting older you know
everything's a lot now well Zach you're
still ignorant and you're still
irresponsible yeah pretty much off
every
day Zach you should have came with us to
uh Universal for Hall weekends I feel
like you would have liked that n it's
too much what do you want to much you
know what I mean I'm not going to pay
okay Goldie Lock what the is are
you talking Halloween Horror Nights you
know listen love true love is out there
but if you look for it it was like 80
bucks you can't expect you can't expect
true love to find you you have to also
put in the work right I've tried man I'm
in therapy
it's over there that's that's the
beginning of it's existential dread bro
Zach did you even eat one piece of candy
yesterday I did yes you did what which
one uh I had a uh a rizzler rler sorry a
rizzler bro
rler see it wasn't even Halloweeny of
enough hold on look at this post look
it's on you it's definitely on it's not
dude I've looked everywhere it's just
dead bro it's not true I went
trick-or-treating I went trick-
or-treating you did where' you go yeah I
just went to some place outside down
yeah it was popping as people
dancing in the streets Halloween
creepy houses all spider web and I
was hey yo it's my first I didn't I was
just going to walk around and then I
just accidentally got into the line for
the cand you can't trick or treat as a
person I accidentally did I was just
walking around and did they give you
candy cuz the the streets were super
slow right and I accidentally got in
line and they're like here's candy I was
like oh you
know well you know as in a as a parent I
just steal it from the boys right I CU I
was like I'm not going to steal the
candy from the kids uh but I was happy
to have
that it was a gumy bears oh nice haros
oh yeah yeah we got a whole bunch of
those you know you did give me some hope
Ean when I do have kids that maybe it
will be sparked again Yes Man
work having kids
being po a baby up it's so true that if
you feel like your youth is is like gone
and you feel like you're in a black hole
of Misery the best way to fill that hole
despite how ready you are or your
financial situation or even the quality
of your relationship is to have kids
immediately yeah if you're depressed and
unhappy with yourself definitely have
kids and take everything out on them
dude I'm going to have the coolest
kid ever too you will bro yeah I
could see that he's going to come out
with like long hair and just be like you
he's going to be
yeah yeah get to work man I'm telling
you
yeah poor Zach yeah I guess she's the
part of getting older you know I'm I'm
exaggerating a bit but I do feel it you
know no I see the pain on you I know
you're not I know I get what you mean I
actually do remember like I it was a
little bit earlier than 26 I would say
but that that realization that you're
too old for Halloween
and you been old foreen you know what I
mean I mean you lose the Halloween
rights at like 15 yeah that's why yeah
for me it was a little bit 26 but it
evolves you know you get to watch
scarier movies as you grow up you get to
go to adult Halloween parties get to
drink you know it's way better you get
yeah know it's awesome I get a headache
from drinking now man I'm a ass
this guy is always ketching about Zach
is 20 six
he's is that avening bro yeah
bro I'm an like old my Grandma coming
out I'm an old Jew man what do you
expect yeah we'll we'll work on
something maybe next year we got to do a
segment where we we got to get Zach out
there to have the best night of his life
what do you think that's interesting I'm
down to do that we all go trick or
treating include Jimmy Lee oh that'll
make it the worst night of my life that
could be fun though that could be he
he's my demon bro he's my uh sleep
paralysis demon yeah I understand I
understand your relationship with him is
complicated AB you guys were back at
horror night wasn't that like the third
time this you guys been there a lot we
get our money's worth of our season's
pass over there oh you have a universal
season pass yeah and you can use them on
horor night that's a separate pass we
got that too cuz we had family visiting
us so we figured why not if you go two
times that already pays for the pass so
you have a horror night season pass yeah
holy yeah we don't around well
that's why I like it it's like a
compromise between being a kid because
you still get to enjoy that stuff but uh
yeah love almost didn't get in cuz he
tried to bring a knife in oh what
the dude you had to slash the
monster you some up in
there
Castle yo guys it's castle doctrine I
did bring a small knife but I forgot it
I didn't it was like a pocket knife
right and I always have it in my little
how big was the blade maybe like like
this big could you kill someone with it
if you were determined of and they
stopped you when they looked through
your bag and saw knife and I said what
are you going to do about it they were
like are we going to throw no yeah yeah
they they said I'm going to throw it up
I like hell no you're not so I went on
like right outside the freaking thing
and I buried it he buried his treasure
like air blade yeah he said happy
Halloween and then and then you
came back and dug it up yeah that's kind
of Genius S I ain't walking back all the
way to the see that sounds like fun dude
that sounds like fun if only
someone invited you you could have been
there I don't want to go a knif over
wait what are you talking about you just
said it sounds fun that's what burying a
knife and getting in trouble that sounds
fun and that's part of it we could have
got in trouble you could have been there
man
mhm rip have you buried Treasures like
that before was that an on thefly
decision I've done it before many it's
smart it's really smart we went with
love to Disneyland like 4 days after
that and he brought the knife again we
had to go back to the car for the second
time nowhere to bury it you know what I
will say it's kind of comforting to know
that the security did find the knife
yeah that is you never know you always
wonder how good are these guys oh man at
twitchcon they did not give a they
literally didn't search my bag I had a
bunch of equipment and stuff good to
know for next year yeah yeah stay at
home on twitchcon next year should i b
that they had um or is that okay that
okay they had sounds like it's good
advice to be
frank they had metal detectors at
twitchcon but I don't even think they
were plugged in
I walk right through it I me that
company is something else man they don't
give a they're like bro you'll be
doing us a favor if you kill half of the
people here see was that okay no I
button
that and the joke being of course is
that they're probably losing money you
know uh right I think we lost the
opportunity to button I I think it was
fine
yeah well if they cared they would they
would plug in the metal detector that's
the least they could do
yeah
anyway I had a great time with the boys
when you're not there you're not there
you're not there
I night a nightmare a nightmare I
can't you're not there dude this song is
crazy hard
[Music]
by the way speaking of dream remixes
remember to get your remixes in my
friends yes they've started to trickle
in I've got some good ones to me Monday
is the deadline right or did we say
Wednesday next Wednesday and there's a
flare on the subreddit so if you post go
on there make sure you use that flare
here's some new ones I got I'll just
play give
you here hold on Zach let me play this
new one we
[Music]
got
oh sorry what
happened what's happening wait are you
playing yeah this is a file I was
just I just want to give it a little
taste
yeah just to give the people an sense of
what what's up
there all right that's a little house
musicy
look at
this yo that's a cool ass baby bro why
is the baby older than the
[Music]
dad
dude that's crazy that one goes hard so
that's what I'm saying it's pretty
exciting oh yeah pretty exciting you
know oh yeah I was meaning to show you
guys
this uh my little sister got this when
she was
trick-or-treating I was relieved to see
so many people in chat saying they've
had similar experiences oh hi
sisters the choice is yours if you
aren't biblically biblically saved at
the moment you are a heart feet away
from hell oh no Eternal and unavoidable
punishment in the Lake of Fire is
waiting for you with no hope of ever
getting out you must prepare for your
death today tomorrow may be too
late hell hell is an everlasting burning
place where there will be weeping
wailing nashing of teeth a little nosh a
little
pach a place of regret where the smoke
of those tormented goes up forever and
they find no rest there night can you
imagine I'm I'm just I go to hell I'm
like I'm just burning alive forever in
the most unimaginable pain and it's like
oh if only I didn't eat pork or
I don't
know just some trivial that God
wants to torture your soul with forever
yeah I knew I shouldn't have eaten pork
and then the dude up in heaven who like
raped kids his whole life is like you
should have trusted Jesus
Jesus yo that God's whack bro anyway
that's up that's crazy to hand to
a kid what's crazy I was asking my mom
I'm like how the hell did they even get
him in the bag and I think what they did
was like they would hide him behind the
candy or attach him to the candy and
then put him in your bag they're
terrorist and what it's not the people
that would like leave it out yeah
they're sneaking in they're sneaking in
deadly packages Pro Terror that's
horrible what a miserable you got
to be here's a here is this children on
fire dying
H what what you're doing or who are
these children once who are these people
on fire people in hell I shouldn't have
uh or
Babushka oh Babushka you should have
listened to me has a little babushka I
told you Jesus was the
way this is a uniquely Christian thing
right or or you said that you're no but
like this level of like oh no I I think
we got them be you guys got them beat we
got them we don't believe you could just
repent in the way I think too late we
can you know make up some prayers and
stuff but it's not like just you can't
wipe the board clean oh that's in the
same way so what happens if you're like
looking for redemption in the in Islam
if you're like a horrible person you've
done horrible things but then you f come
to God and you go and you come to Islam
is there a path to Redemption well we
believe it's a scale you got more Good
Deeds or bad Deeds oh so you got to do
lots of good yeah well that's a
good that's a good
yeah I like that actually um the uh
Buddhist hell is like is pretty gnarly
too they give the Christians a run for
the money the what happens in hel and
Buddhism it's like I think well the one
thing I know about is they it's you go
there for like a billion billion years
which sounds bad but then I'm realizing
in Christianity it's literally forever
so I guess that is longer than a billion
forever isn't Hindu kind of funny too
cuz you'll be reborn as a rock and
you've got to be a good rock to become
I don't think a rock I think I think a
rock but another living you could be
reborn as as an insect or something
that's what I'm saying what's a good
rock one that has Jade in it I was going
to say we're going to cut up on some
rock that's a blessing to be reborn as
Jade also the well the theory in Hindu
that's really wild is like if you're
broke it's cuz you were an in in
your past life it's not I mean I'm I'm
not a Hindu I'm not but karma it's a
little bit more uh complicated is that
it you you you get reincarnated on a on
like a field of how yes you you uh you
you are reincarnated based on the
actions past but um but it's a there's
some Nuance you know and that that's a
that works great for the people who make
up the rules they're like dude I'm the
best I was the best in my past life man
that's why I have all the money and all
the power right I was awesome in
my past life this life you know I'm
doing my best but in the past lives I
was killing it dude perfect I was
killing it think in Islam and I could be
maybe Lena knows but I think you don't
stay forever in hell I think it's you
have to make up for the bad you
did I don't know but like Hitler I don't
see him getting out someone like that
yeah you know Lena yeah I think it's
like how you described it you just make
up for your sins and
everyone I don't know everyone when
you're in hell do you make up or or you
just serve your time yeah like you serve
your time you just serve your time
depends what sha you ask so hell is just
like the US Penitentiary
system yeah good pretty much hell
there's no demons or fire oh there is
yeah and in your guys's yeah yeah and
I've heard different things I told the
story once on the show about a chea said
that your soul will be like locked in a
box and then that box will be shot with
like flaming arrows what the yeah
it's like extra strength fire not normal
fire and I was about to say super fire I
couldn't remember off the top of my head
but now I'm reading some of the things
that happen in Buddhist hell um for
example having molten metal dropped on
you being sliced into pieces over and
over again suffering from the iron
ground they're like really descriptive
about uh the because you had too
much rice like what why are you going to
hell in Buddhism no no you have to be a
pretty terrible person to go to hell in
Buddhism really yeah yeah I respect that
yeah yeah but I'm just saying they're
very specific about the torture methods
like they spell out for you so read
those again uh let's see if this is just
one layer of Hell there are uh uh there
are eight great hot Hells apparently uh
let's
see uh as soon as uh the beings begin to
fear being harmed by others their
fellows appear and attack each other
with iron Claws and Hell guard appear
and attack them with fiery weapons it
sounds like sounds kind Diablo this is
tier one yeah that's the lightest one
yeah as soon as the being experiences an
unconsciousness like death they are
suddenly restored to full health and the
attack begins again so you're constantly
getting you're respawning and then
getting hacked to Pieces over and over
and I hate billions of years
right they Camp you exactly
sucks what's the last Circle uh let's
see if we go all the way down
um uh inter beings are roasted in an
immense blazing oven with terrible
suffering um it's right the one turns a
circle is said to last as long as and
then this is a Sanskrit word that I do
not know um an eon an eon I think that
took a million years yeah what what Yuga
I think it's a million no it's
anara I'm sorry I'm probably saying that
wrong 1.3
million oh a palpa is 4 oh here we go a
palpa is 4.32 billion
years um and I think that this is
like a kalpa kalpa oh Anon is a billion
years okay so yeah you know
it's it's for a while just for a little
while it's for a while okay and what do
you have to do to go to Buddhist Health
same thing as other heals you kill
people you yeah exactly you you get a
lot of Bad Karma I believe again I'm not
I'm by no means an expert on this but do
they have like where you eat pork
and then you go to hell or is it's more
severe um well uh you are highly
encouraging in Buddhism to be a
vegetarian you're uh and to not harm
other sentient beings and so in a way
kill you forever in a way
yes it's crazy man there's so much
misinformation about Islam online I was
looking at the seven levels of Hell in
Islam and it literally says two of the
levels one of them is for Jews and one's
for Christians which is it's just not
true it's it's insane oh
interesting so so they're they were
saying incorrectly that the Jews and
Christians have their own little special
place in hell yeah it's that's so
get wild it's one of the first I think
verses is like if we're not uh something
about we're all CH children of God some
like that so wait what happens to
people who are not of the Muslim faith
when they die um I asked my uncle this
once he was very religious and he said
that uh he believes and a lot of people
believe that Christians and Jews will go
to heaven like cuz uh all the Believers
of the book so I love that yeah and I
was like what well cuz my best friend
who is Hindu so I was like oh what about
you know
Hindus they're
okay oh that's awesome I don't
believe that but oh I like that at least
like as the as the updates came like the
tent gets bigger I like that you got and
we should I mean I will I will stand up
for the Christians in the audience a
little bit like any religion there are
so many denominations everything and not
all Christians think that all
non-christians are going to hell there's
a wide variety of beliefs Christian for
the record when I say this is a uniquely
Christian thing I just
mean that in America I don't think
anyone's handing you this uh who's not I
would say this may be a uniquely
Evangelical Christian to hand this out
on Halloween yes if you don't believe in
Jesus Christ you are wrong there I mean
okay there it is whatever he said I was
told like really scary stuff growing up
about like if I for example if you don't
wear the hijab or the head scarf you go
to hell for as many years as as many
strands of hair you have which isn't
that's a lot yeah we all got one ant
that us up a little bit that's
what I've learned in Islam at least yeah
they scare you away from religion I feel
like and that's not true like most
importantly you have to be a good person
and be good to others can I ask you
question if you go to hell for each
strain of hair on your head if you're
lose if you go bald are you good are you
clean loophole maybe maybe loophole yeah
I don't know how to answer that
that's what the Orthodox do they live
for loopholes they like turn their
lights on before Shabbat so they are
they have like dude I don't know if you
guys have seen what the Orthodox do they
have like R Goldman devices to like so
they don't have to do work on the
Sabbath technically they're not allowed
to like use power or do anything or
tools nothing and so they have all these
Ru gold their house is like PB Herman's
house you know when they wake up and
they just I know exactly what you just
turn on the light at that point
man you're not fooling God he knows what
you're
doing anyway we kid the religious don't
we folks we love them they got like the
breakfast machine exactly exactly we
love them I've even heard that some just
hire people to be there to turn on
for
them Orthodox Jews I mean technically
not doing the work somebody else is I
know but like who we fool God said don't
work not working the point is sit with
your loved ones and you reflect I or
read the Torah whatever that's the idea
but if you're just going to have like
people do it for you then it's just like
a a dope vacation
Vibe we got to change with the times you
know busy people people need work too
people need work there you go everyone
needs
work oh we kid them we love the
religious yeah we love God we love the
piest love you God jeo
um oh shout out to Nathan actually who
made the Halloween background I didn't
know that oh the one from yeah and it
was so wonderfully detailed I saw there
was like a Mobility mared there's Zach
kimosabe in the doorway I saw that's so
awesome all the pumpkins are us yeah
that's great well that's so nice thank
you I think that's you on a Mobility
Scooter going right going by in the
distance there so that's Nathan Sam we
love the tree branches say H3 too no way
yeah that's cool nice um nice all right
here's the thing I have a ton
of fun stories to get to but because of
the the Jade uh Jade n's here let's get
started on that because we're going to
be drilling open stones and it might
take a moment yes true so with all that
being said let's let's get on with the
Jade
Nation hit us
[Music]
Ian oh his eyes wow beautiful oh my
god
[Music]
wow oh my God you know nicely done
nicely done good I hear people I see
people they walk around with the golden
grills and diamonds and stuff to flex
I'm working on my jade grills right up
in this actually no I'm pulling them all
out and replace them with Jade I hear
they're really durable so
anyway let's introduce our uh should we
bring out the Jade
Nation so here are the three lovely
um gem enthusiasts who have been kind
enough to come here and help us set up
my obsession with Jade Cutting Jade
harvesting in China unon unan province
which is my retirement my dream
retirement please join us thank you guys
thank you
everybody Jaden
H thank you guys so
um you guys want to introduce yourselves
oh do you you guys each have a mic there
you just got to hold it really close to
your mouth
yeah okay you guys do you mind
introducing yourselves yeah so um I'm
aara um I uh manage the crystal shop um
and I do most of my mining in the
Central Coast okay and and you are I'm n
I'm Emily's partner okay awesome and so
are you a gem Enthusiast or are you just
by proxy yes you're oh yeah we got a oh
yeah and then and you are uh I'm Emerald
uh I just mine crystals and I cut them
so you are you are and is it Jade that
you love specifically or you love all
precious gems or all gems we love all
precious gems for sure we love anything
that the Earth spits out that doesn't
look like a normal rock is a winner it's
a winner it's a winner and your name is
Emerald is that uh By Design well my
name's Emily but Emerald is way way more
cool and fitting it is it is that's
great Emerald fantastic
[Music]
J and so were you guys aware of this
whole gambling and Union uh phenomenon
before we were talking about it you know
if you don't mind be like right up under
it um yeah so like I I've seen videos
like it but I didn't see like the really
funny ones like the ones that you were
showing on the podcast and me and that
were watching we're like what is this
goofy Shenanigans like why we don't
throw our rocks we're done with them
we're like okay well it's a trash rock
I'll throw it in my yard and I'll slice
it into tile and masonry or something
you know cuz it's still like a cool
colored Rock it's not just like a normal
Rock it's a almost Jade which is
probably some sort of like Serpentine or
serper tonight the thing is Jade is kind
of like Jade is it's kind of boring Jade
is kind of boring in terms of
the it's just one
color it's one color about how there are
so many really cool crystals that are
they will blow your mind like Google
vanat night and you you'll think it's
fake like uh boright it's real it's all
like there's so many really cool like
ovite and stuff and then like the Jade
is awesome don't get me wrong but like
this is just the gateway drug Jade is
the gateway drug Jade is the gateway
drug you guys are going to be obsessed
with crystals by the end of this cuz
there's so much more than one color rock
well let me ask you this you said Jade
is only green
for the most part purple and white I got
to I got to flex my expertise go for it
it can be white black or green
so so true bestie I mean you know more
than there's blue Jade there's blue Jade
there's blue Jade in PGA County they
have the white vesuvianite Jade in PGA
which is just called poga Jade mm poga
we have a variety we have a variety and
so um are you guys do you believe like
the crystals and rocks have like magic
powers or you I'm extremely agnostic
with like religious like overall I
didn't grow up in a religious family at
all and so it like the thought of
religion came along a lot later in my
life cuz like it just never was a thing
and so I've just been like is there
ghosts is there not is this rock helping
me out is it not I don't know but my
love for the Rocks really just comes
from like the fact that the Earth spat
out something that's shiny and green
like look at Rainbow Lati Sunstone how
the how does that exist how does that
exist and someone didn't just like make
it themselves like right it's a coinci
Love of the Game just love of the stones
and then also like Minecraft like just
getting in my van and going out in the
desert and then just dude you just got
to find a book called gem Trails go to
any old library ask them if they have
anything with the word gem trails in it
and it's like pirate maps every County
will have every I mean California has
any gem you can think of you would be
really surprised at how many rocks you
can find just going outside sometimes
you might might have to go to like a
little bit of a nature trail but you'll
find them sometimes you don't have to
dig they're just like on the ground
right I've seen yeah I'm real curious
about the process this is the uh yeah
the one favorite Stone my favorite
rainbow how's it called rainbow laat
Sunstone
yeah do we use these stones for
decorative purposes I don't know that
I've seen this I use them for a lot of
lots of people use them for jewelry oh
okay most people use them for jewelry um
I like to use them as decoration and in
terms of like do they have any healing
properties maybe but they heal my mental
health maor you're in school I am an
ecology major so I do uh know a little
bit about rocks and minerals um I like
to use them I know a lot more about the
rock terrari you know a lot more about
like how they're made and how they're
what they're made out of minerals and
stuff yeah what is the theory about the
crystals um affecting the mood or
Vibes I think to be honest I think Shiny
Rock pretty make brain happy that's good
I think that's how it goes that's
wonderful and we love that these watch
they are beautiful that's really cool so
um you guys brought a huge array of
rocks for us all pick from do you guys
want to
um so you guys can you tell me about the
process of uh collecting these rocks so
it was a fun one and it was it was a fun
process okay so we drove uh eight hours
in one day there in to here from Central
California to Jade Cove in Big Sir and
we rock climbed down a cliff uh
something that we're very good at we are
very professional at rock climbing down
to get Jade not anything any Rock not
just Jade uh this is our little uh
Venture you guys in Big Sir yeah so we
got there at night time and so we were
like I've done this before in the
daytime so I'll just have to use all of
my memory the reason you did this at
night is Just because uh it was the day
before yesterday okay just in a in a
hurry by the way as as you were touching
on they are trained professionals we
have done this one specifically before
too do not go spelunking uh that's
asbest coming out of the wall asbest
well like Jade is just asbest that has
sat and okay so AAR it's like asbestos
Serpentine and then it turns into like
serpentinite and then jadeite sanite
jadeite yeah and then it becomes Jade so
if you so you don't want to breathe uh
Jade dust there's a place that I go to
called Clear Creek and you're only
legally allowed to go there seven times
a year because the the ground is green
and it's like a 10 20% like uh made up
of just asbest and dirt so you're not
supposed to go there like a lot oh
you guys wear masks and stuff when
you're around these kinds of materials
or manmade asbest is a lot worse than
naturales like the the crystals and uh
man-made asbest is really small uh
fibers but the natural fibers are way
too long to get as easily caught in you
but they still bad but it's not like a
big deal and your thoughts on lead add
it to the wine uh good or bad uh
definitely I put that is
lead I personally shave lead into my
drinks you shave lead I've heard it
tastes very good although I wouldn't
recommend it if to anyone watching yeah
gamer Subs by the way as you touched on
does not have le I have to shave it into
it like good just to match with uel
thank you for mentioning that by the way
yeah so um you guys went down to Big Sir
it looks like you guys climbed down to
some kind of Rocky uh terrain what what
made you guys choose this specific
location well there's a lot of just
every Rock on the ground is either
Serpentine serpent tonight or Jade
nothing there isn't a green rock that's
going to either is Jade or become Jade
or have Jade inside of it and I could
have gone to Clear Creek it would have
been fun but I was worried that I'd get
too much jadeite which takes so long to
cut it would have just been a nightmare
because that so much harder than Jade
really it's probably is it worth more
than Jade sometimes Jade it depends on
the quality yeah everything depends on
quality it depends on the quality what
the Purity is mineral content what is
this Dan this is our Recreation oh this
is you guys yes oh wait hold on is there
audio okay it's like this is perfect I
got to Creek in my backyard and I'm like
okay we're doing this this is your
backyard oh that's sick is there audio
here's us touching the blade wait it's
spinning and you're touching it like
that oh that's so interesting it's like
a file so it you'll feel it scrape you
but it's not serrated oh that's so stick
your
funger and so are all oh you got the
flashlight yeah
awesome yes see Ethan the real art to
Jade cutting it's not about just cutting
the Jade in half the real art to it is
letting out letting your anger go with
the Jade right for the pieces that that
are garbage you you get it out that's
free therapy right there that's probably
my favorite part about those videos
that's where the cost is is the free
therapy that the rocks are you just
that's where they heal you as well
that's the that's the healing power it's
a beautiful
demonstration absolutely wow it's like a
free rec room yes and so exactly are all
these rocks from the same location or
are they no aery of like all of our
different Rock trips cuz we have a lot
we have a lot of variety here is just
full of different trips and you'll like
see rocks from this are like ones that
I've gotten in Tik toks in the past
before so this is just a long time
building of just a collection and you
looking at these know which one are
oh we know which ones they are really
that's why they wrap up the Jade in the
videos cuz those people are so smart
they're going to know when you know what
it looks like you can spot it and then
it kind of that there's somewhere you
don't have to cover it up where it's
like you don't really know because the
outside could well looks can be
deceiving with rocks looks can be very
deceiving you have to you have to think
and know what's inside cuz the outside
is not always going to match okay and so
in these three baskets of of rocks there
is how many Stones would you guys say
like seven seven and so the way we're
going to do it is each one we're going
to take turns purchasing a jade stone
from the vendors here and we are going
to saw them open and see who's the big
winner and who are the fat
losers
losers but they get to throw it they get
that release
they when you guys watching those uh gay
uh Jade gambling videos it sounds like
they are valuable but also they're not
like that valuable District that they
are they're all so all the stones they
have you see are round they're mostly
using River Jade in these gambling uh
videos so like I would almost say that
they just have so much and especially in
that Province cuz like a lot of the cost
of stones for me too are like I'll pay I
have these little labite uh Palm stones
that I get for like 30 cents a piece but
the shipping for them adds a dollar so
then it's $130
but a whole dollar of that was just the
weight of the rock shipping and freight
and so like if they wanted to ship these
like garbage pieces out to somewhere
where they are worth more it would still
cost a lot to ship these heavy rocks so
like they they probably do just Chuck
them but like we don't have a lot of
Jade in California so it's so but is it
possible that they can actually like get
rich when they F find like a fat
beautiful Jade the Jade itself most raw
rocks aren't necessarily um very desired
um but when they're polished when
they're cabbed if they're carved into
jewelry people that immediately like UPS
the value by like tenfold so it depends
on what you do with the Jade that
determines its value but my guess is
that like the people who are selling the
Jade to them they're making their profit
because they're selling each one no
matter what and then they
also the people who are buying them are
probably making a little bit of a profit
cuz they wouldn't do it if they were
just losing and losing well that is
gambling yeah but I think it's like not
like gambling where you go to a casino
where it is the odds are so against you
that like sometimes you're going to win
I think it's like a true 50/50 so it's
like but I I feel like he loses all this
he probably filmed a lot of like the
dramatic ones too that's the game I need
to that's the game was telling me a lot
about it I wish I had asked him more
because he actually has been over there
and he like he was telling me uh about
how the their River stones and how like
they they just do the whole gambling
thing over there about where the the the
gambling oh oh oh yeah wonderful unit
Province I uh consider my my future home
I believe I'm a Zionist and I believe
yunan is the future Homeland we use all
that garbage Jade to make a jade mansion
and then all thees will be the nice Jade
hell yeah that's what I need right there
um very good so as you were saying it's
more about how you process it cuz I've
notice a lot of the guys when they get a
fat Jade stone they'll like carve it
into some kind of beautiful ston wor
that's where the money's that's where
the money is that nice stone for sure
but then you have to make it into
something that you can't just sell a
rock to a person most people don't just
want a rock in their house most people
want like a decoration that's not just a
rock I like the Rocks as they are my
phone I always wondered if it was a if
they're selling it to like rock people
who uh you know process the rocks or if
they process the Rocks but there's just
it's just a beautiful
um it is just it's just a beautiful
situation out there in
un it seems symbiotic to me okay you
think everyone's winning I think like
the people are selling them the mine
owners are the ones who are winning
right like they can just pull the stuff
out of the ground and then just sell it
how do they get these
rocks what's you can get them from a lot
of places
go get them what's the process of like
these big ass mines do you think so like
are it's different if you're talking
about what they do in Canada where they
have a giant to keep like yeah sorry um
it's different like where in Canada
where they have these giant like
hillsides where they have to just get
this giant saw and actually chop it so
they it's something they can get but um
from what I see all of the unon Jade is
uh just River stones that they probably
get from like a nearby deposit Where the
River washes it away that's what Clear
Creek is in central California okay and
is there there's always new Stones being
washed every rainy season for a lot more
I get um a lot of the serpentine that I
get here I got from the Central Coast
just because like there are mountains of
it like literal hillsides made out of
this rock that's really cool yeah and
you can just go outside and get them for
free the biggest the first thing my galy
teacher said was uh there's no such
thing as a rare gemstone no such thing
nothing it is all like you have these um
these mine owners and people who have
collector pieces and a lot of these
really really fine collector pieces
you'll never see they're not going to
post about them they're going to lock
them away in the vault uh I I can't
exactly remember why like the really
like million dooll uh collector pieces
they don't even show them or post them
online some of the other really nice
pieces they'll show and then they will
so like lapis mins from what I heard
right now is they're only like selling
some and they're closing it off for
certain times of the year to bring the
value up because they have so much of it
and if they just keep putting it out
it's just going to keep losing its value
and so they release how much of certain
crystals certain mines like there's only
one a couple places in the world where
lapis comes from too so they really have
like they have a monopoly on the
absolutely on the mining of it oh
totally whereas something like Jade you
can just go find but there's a lot of
mine owners who acquire mines and they
can't sell their crystals too so there's
a like mine owners aren't synonymous
with just having a ton of money there's
like the people who have like Emerald
mines like Elon dad and then there's the
people who just have like like I know
this guy in Morocco who has an Instagram
account where he has just tons and tons
and tons of these quartz crystals he's
trying to sell he's always coming to me
being like I will literally give you a
pallet for $20 and it's like I know but
I can't ship it here for cheap enough um
I like have to get a lot of my stuff
like I get Arkansas's uh courts a lot
because it's a lot closer and they drive
it here to the uh gem shows and like
court site in January but like this guy
will try and because there's so much
it's not rare no such thing as rare
crystals and so they'll have basically
these certain M owners that have like
cheaper crystals are going to be like a
dollar for 100 pounds and they'll try
and underbid each other and so they're
doing this hard hard labor just like
actual slave labor because like wage
slaves but to a nuclear lover making
like pennies off are you talking about
what happens in like
uh or Myanmar we've seen like all the
people with under tractors it's okay I
mean Crystal mining it it is so hard to
ethically source and it is so important
to ethically Source too because it is
just so I mean it is such a saint that
you can just get whatever you want in
California it's less than a six- hour
driveway it's great we love California
also I want to mention that like the
price the value is all arbitrary like
it's all like orchestrated it's it's
it's decided by like you know whoever uh
get discovers it or has the mine um a
lot of rocks don't really have intrinsic
value it's and they're also not all
trade names are lus trade names are wait
what do you mean trade names so like
there's so different rocks it's not
selenite just there's so many examples
just how is magnesite actually well so
there's this Crystal called magnesite
but it got called howly because it sells
better and not how light um but everyone
calls it that now so people actually
consider it okay call it how like lots
of crystals have different names or
names that are made up because it either
sells better or because there's like for
example lepidolite and pink turmaline
those are two crystals that people like
but when you get them from the mine
they're going to be like mixed up with
like smoky quartz and black turmaline
and it kind of looks a mess but people
online they'll sell those jumbled mes as
like unicorn Stone and suddenly it's
worth more but the rock is worthless a
marketing it's all marketing and a lot
of rocks and minerals that are like
different still are made out of the same
composition it's just about like the
pigmentation and like the purity of the
rock but like like for Jade there's a
lot of rocks that have Jade in it
it's just the whole thing isn't going to
be like that but at uh in Big Sir you'll
see Boulders that have veins of Jade in
them Wow have you guys ever found I know
you guys are saying the price is
arbitrary but I'm curious if yall have
ever found something that was valuable
that you were able to I found a lot of
uvarovite which is California Green
Garnet which is Plas plasma agot yeah
it's only from have you been able to
sell any of this stuff so like um I can
trade it for a lot so or what I like to
do is I can mine a ton of plasma agot
and then I can mail it
plasma it's only from California it's
located in one area and that's it one
place and I'll get Boulders I'll mail
them to my processing I know a lot of
facilities in China yeah that's the guy
I want there's prettier examples of that
there's way prettier examples so is it
worth it to send it all the way to China
cuz the I send it to them they cut it
for free as long as I let them keep a
portion of it oh and it's like kind of a
little
tra interesting this is so World of
Warcraft like CRA I know that collecting
all these GS give it to the CRA giving
me ever request are you trying to say
aot a is that a a okay I'm having
flashbacks to the I say Agate Agate but
like Trisha would agree yeah she would
aate it's so
silly it's okay
Zach so um very interesting very good
and so I guess let's let's there was one
thing you mentioned on a previous show
and I wasn't watching live because I was
trying to get stuff done for this I
always watch live too so it was like so
annoying and you're like oh we could get
an Ethan a jade Ethan head I I can have
that made it's like you can make a jade
Ethan head I don't remember requesting
that but I'll take it I think that there
was wait no there was something I can't
remember but Dan was like if you're
listening emerald and I just
remember I we'll we'll get get you a
jade Ethan head we'll get you a jade
carving Ethan head yeah I can have we
can do that for sure hell yeah confused
speaking
of we have gifts for you guys oh yes
I've heard thank you how big are we
talking I can do any size like life
size oh my God I don't do we have Jade
that big we have a boulder of Jade this
big we could like the usable Jade is
going to be like this that's the thing
when you carve Jade when you carve any
rock or mineral you lose a good
percentage of the Mass mhm that's the
thing and that's like it's painful when
I watch Like carving and stuff because
I'm like I had my um what do we use that
like a little Dremel to do carving I
don't have the stuff myself uh but I
definitely can have it yeah if you can
make one you know like a uh you know God
it's so funny year 200 uh Chi Dynasty uh
Emerald Relic know what they're going to
think when I give them this reference
photo they're like we can do it I don't
know why you want it yeah what why what
what don't you
understand um
so here's the game we're each going to
go up we're going to
purchase a stone we are going to switch
off for the sake of fairness and once
all of this St what Dan is getting
excited and you know train baby my
reputation is on the line here a little
bit so if I'm hoping I need to be
getting some Jade out of this otherwise
I'm going to look like a damn
fool but uh so we're going to take turns
and then you guys are going to go
downstairs saw them open you guys
brought your saw and then we are going
to
assess the Geo uh the geological
value expertise of the picture thank
you oh we got Boba for everybody you
guys got Boba right yeah I was so close
to Bringing Boba for everybody okay I
was so close but I was like okay I
probably shouldn't bring any food just
because of logistical reasons we got it
we got it all right so let's go ahead
and get started on the The Rocks let's
go yeah I'm going to go
[Applause]
first hello okay so go ahead and take a
look here AB should I now based on what
I
know this looks like Jade but I feel
like like
that's this is a a decoy I don't I don't
think so I'm not going for that one and
again this one I'm getting the
same type of thing but again I I I don't
trust the what's this this is not
Jade this could be
Jade I'm curious is there shungite in
there shung we have a piece of shungite
oh wait can is shungite real I never
actually found out or not
uh one
of so shungite is a real Stone it's it's
a rock yeah oh okay and does it block 5G
um debatable I feel protected if you
believe it
does so this one is speckled with green
but it's not very luminous do I can I do
a flashlight
test I don't let's
see I
mean we're we're you know we're apply
here can you hold this we're just you
know okay so as you guys can see this is
not Jade this is dark as night I
suck this is
but then so let's test one of
these ones oh wow wait hold on hold
on because this one's glowing but that
might have too much Bloom on it too
because sometimes I've heard folks say
that sometimes it's too glowy and it's
fake Jade got remember Jade
no can you talk on the mic dude look at
the glow on that man that is Luminous th
look at that look at the lumens does it
work okay you got to remember that the
this Jade is from a different Source
from everything you've looked at so it's
it's going to look a lot different so
this one is not real jade or maybe I
dude this one's Jade I mean what do you
say about that glove there's a lot of
green minerals here of wide variety
could be green but not Jade that's what
I'm concerned about I feel like it's I'm
being misled okay I'm leaning towards
this one do the oh so I should take this
one I have enough for I feel like the
I'm not going to I'm not not going to
look this is the one I'm going to pick
this is one you just want to pick one oh
are we going to we're going to take
turns I thought oh okay cuz I all right
all right okay cool so then so this is
one all
right I mean this I mean what we oh
that's super
[Applause]
luminous wait holy
well how am I cheating cuz the
flashlight sorry that I'm a
trained
professional so hold on glowing is not
necessarily indicative of the J not
always of a different Crystal outside
because like a lot of the Jade is just
like a pocket on the inside of the
serpent tonight and Serpentine this one
is real glowy though let's see so I
these one you know these ones are dark
there's nothing happening here you know
these one this one actually this one is
this one is
promising there's a
lot this is a very complicated Rock
there's a lot Happening Here never in my
life did I think I would watch Ethan
Klein go through my rock collection with
a
flashlight it's very surreal how am I
doing so far don't answer that I I don't
want to say I'm feeling really good
about this rock okay call that number
two no what what you
doing not yet what what you doing see
that one's quite luminous as
well the color on the outside doesn't
always determine whether it's Jade or
not on the inside so it could be so is
there a wave that you guys would know
how to tell don't tell them no no just
say it's just on experience a hammer
that's oh yeah in the field sometimes
you'll just chip off a piece of The Rock
and look at it thank you look at this
one man golly it's hard to stay I mean
look at this one I mean this one's
luminous as I don't think that's
Jade right or is
it look at I mean it is Luminous it is
beautiful it is green but Jade is it
crystallized or is it more in a vein I
don't know if I've ever seen like Jade
crystals it depends there's different
kinds of jade
Rocks come in all shapes and
sizes okay there's two of these I don't
think this is
Jade what is it though so
luminous what's this what is it all
right I'm going to I'm going to I'm
going to speed it up so let's do
um let's doing maybe this what is this
one oh that's Jade as
hold on this one dude this one this
is fun this is a dream come true for
Ethan but this is even more for me well
I'm excited I'm glad every everyone's
dreams are coming true today everyone
why is it why are they in Water by the
way uh it makes the color a lot better
okay okay I see so I'm going to go with
this big boy here
although you got to go to the court site
gem show dude you think so you have to
go have a end this one Dan you would
have a fi day at the gem showy running
around like oh God do people go around
with flashlights oh yeah oh and then
they it's it's as big as these ones that
you see in the unon and then they have
the giant blade Cutters that are like as
tall as that really there oh it's so
cool and what's the deal with they seem
to have like a special flashlight that
they slam on it a really strong small
flashlight I like that They smash it on
we brought both uh normal wave and
shortwave U VB but we didn't have any
rocks that shine to the short wave
what's so what does this do that doesn't
help with Jade but we wanted to show up
those are for that's to detect C C
minerals that do glow under the light
and we have some right here that's
called that's light yo
sick oh that's so cool thank you guys
what's the process that makes it Glow
it's just how it is it's the mineral
minerals that's
sodalite pink site pink sodalite look at
that Batman one that's so cool
sod oh wow look at the mushroom yeah so
the mushroom that's uh that's Moonstone
and must be there's a calite vein in
there that glows beautiful going to the
Moon baby and this one like glows purple
or is that just the green that's just
refracting reflecting the light that's
just rose quartz beautiful all right
well thank you guys and the these are
gorgeous and I thank you guys so much so
Dan you want to go next since you're
here okay Ethan you didn't slap the
money oh oh oh so you have you
guys have to do I I'll take those three
pleas
[Music]
so it and
then oh yeah oh just take them all then
hold
it slap it last good
luck Will Smith just smack the out
of me thank you guys so much appreciate
that good
luck no no oh wait yes yes yeah it is
all right thank you guys wow wow good
luck all right I'll be a little bit
quicker than Ethan here I'm going to
since we get to Big
Three I'm going to go wild card here I'm
going to do one of these I I don't mean
to be insulting here but one of these
boring looking ones cuz I feel like dude
why would you say that because I mean
look look at how cool these are and then
this just like kind of looks like an
ordinary ass Rock but dude that rock in
no I feel like sometimes they can be
sleepers so you're right you're right
all right so we'll do this one um and
then to hedge my bet I'll do one of
these that has the nice green seams here
yeah I feel like that has o oh look at
that oh wow glorious thank you Cam Glory
Glory Hallelujah when did this turn into
beautiful world beautiful that's a
beautiful stone and um for my last uh
for my last
one let's see see I mean no not that one
this one okay this
one thank you thank you all right those
are my three I'm going for it very good
um here AB you can swap with
me Will Smith just I like that it's
random all right yeah part of the fun is
just going to
be ah I'm trying to be a little quick I
don't know about this but you can
take use the
flashlight you know it's pretty fun want
be a cheater like no I don't I want to
be all random I want want to be random
here I'm going to go I'm going to go
with this one cuz it's green
it's a good choice slap that
um ah is
[Music]
this yes B's being very thoughtful he
took one small Stone he put it back he
wasn't feeling it okay that one looks
real interesting looks like a steak yeah
I like steak okay there we go all
righty okay that one was
fine and uh I'll go with this boy okay
big guys oh that one's not good though
even say it's not Jade there's no way
that one's Jade Right girls ladies
you'll have to see
y'all we'll see cam you want to go
next let's get it big money big
money we get three how many do we pick
three Three Stones cam all right cam is
in his Jade puffer I'm wear it for good
luck yeah love that this one looks cool
so I'm going to go with this one cam is
analyzing puffer well you have theen
jacket on so you're going to have like
this you got like the the St Patrick's
Day Spirit exactly the connection like
attracts like the wavelength slap it on
my jacket real quick there we go so I
put that
there cam is picking is searching want a
big one C went for the black one man I
like the big one big big one yep yeah
I'm not sure about that one but I'm sure
of it that's a big money right there
look at how much imagine how much that
that's going to be uh and
then let me
see we got some money slapping gamma's
picking his final Stone here this is
yeah pressure's on
now we're thinking we're
analyzing and he's picking this one y
and we we got to run over a garbage one
with the Gatsby
the Gatsby is dead we got to run wrist
in peace yeah that's so sad we need to
repair it but at the moment it's out of
in peace all right thank you number
three I'm going to give it a little bird
kiss for good luck too bird kiss to it
that's nice slapping cool thank you big
money money thank you thank you Kim sure
by the way as we're I guess I'll wait
till after we pick the stones but I we
got we did a boba experiment
the Boba experiment the great Boba Wars
I guess I'll talk about it afterwards
okay I just wanted to taste it while it
was like cold and fresh you know what I
mean I think she looks
promising that one little but like maybe
strong you know okay yeah thank you
Olivia's got a nice little rock there
connected with it this
one I got nervous about that one feel
you got scared I did I did it said
something weird feel the energy
pulsating off it
Olivia this close your eyes intuition
this one's saying a lot to me okay yeah
it better not
disappoint and this one is also speaking
a lot to
me I think you're right I you see it
you're you are a stone Mommy I am a
stone mommy Crystal mommy Crystal mmy a
crystal mommy actually the crystal road
trips so I mean if my luck gets better
because I have a crystal I would love
that so may ask you guys is the term
Crystal mommy
derogatory I don't think
so I think I think anybody can be a
crystal Mommy it's a it's a compliment
oh it's a compliment I would say so very
good compliments um let's do one more
just for the sake of brevity
here love you want to you want to get
stoned Let's Get Stoned boy love is
coming up
R mom I want a vape
she oh man this is exciting mom I want
love is wearing his Elon mus shirt so
hopefully that will give in tune you
with the green uh H yeah oh
yeah I think this one looks green that
one looks sick dude this looks like a
Counter Strike
camo take that one I want some big ass
Rock This mother oh true huh I mean
what's the there's not Jade in there you
know if there's Jade in here too that's
a lot of Jade yeah that's a lot of
freaking where do I you can just put it
right here all right oh my go wait do I
go for double juice from aoer I take the
other can I absolutely I feel like
that's the best business DEC whatever
rocks are calling to
you yeah I I'm going to go for those
three all right great thank you love
anyone else want to go Sam you want to
pick s me some yes go ahead Sam okay Sam
is unfortunately getting the slim
pickings here I know he may have
M there's plenty of of winners left
you're saying oh yeah there are oh I've
had my eye on one yeah which one for
like a while let's hear
it something I don't know I could be
wrong
but this one that particular is really
speaking to me it's a pretty one oh
it do you want to do a flashlight test
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay I like it
Picasso what am I looking for with this
lumens lumens you got to put it right up
on
it oh I see I mean it doesn't really you
can also hold it up to the corner of the
edge that's how you get the most we get
that I'm sorry what if it's speaking to
you then take the the corners are the
way to go but this uh flashlight test is
not speaking to hold that's pretty shiny
I mean like yeah but more so than like
this girl right here we get three oh I
get three yep you get three
three give me that one all right
imediately yes let me also you all get
to keep the cut rocks oh thank
you want to keep no not that one that
one is not a
juicer um okay let me try all right I'm
going to be quick I'm be
quick no that thing is dead you guys
left me nothing here they said there's a
bunch there stuff there's stuff yeah
remember looks can be deceiving
the okay I'm really curious about that
one Sam cuz if you hold the flashlight
up to it it's so shiny like put the
flashlight on it it's so
luminous well nothing not I mean not
really it's just
wet yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah we're bringing out hint Sam no
we'll give one little hint and that has
to and it has to do with the weight of
the weight all right is it like consider
the weight of the Jade
heavy well is Jade heavy or light mine
super heavy it's a little dense it's a
little dense I mean this one's kind of I
really like this one I'm going to go
this one's well marbled like a steak I'm
going to go for that one and
then you know
what I'm going to Sam is uh agonizing
over her final Rock chice there she's
picked three all right have our pick
thank you oh then we have Lina do you
want to pick three go
ahead
exciting Ian you want to pick money got
s too hard that's what I'm talking about
let's get Ian out
here oh the water makes it pop a lot of
uh rocks are pretty dry and that doesn't
show color very well that's why when you
buy rocks usually they're polished and
so water water shows you what the
polishing is going to look like think so
it looks
gorgeous Lena is checking with the
flashlight this is my this is one I'm
real curious about yeah I don't think a
lot of you went with these colors nobody
picked one of those okay I want to go
with this one the Chicken McNugget and
it's glowy man it is glowy who went
before love oh this is
pretty I
did Lena is going through o I like this
one too okay that one's pretty do you
guys ever like look for gold you know I
went gold panning a lot when I was a kid
but
like it's it's a novelty like if you
want to make money off of gold you have
to have like machinery and go under the
ocean or to Canada oh really tear out
hillsides
so I have a set of options these are
mine they just they live out of their
car they go around they find rocks they
take them to gem shows and sell them and
that's their business and they will do
gold and these people are awesome these
are a lot of my friends
so cool that's really cool there's this
uh crackhead who lives in front of Jade
Cove I think he got arrested recently
though but uh he cleared out Jade Cove
pretty much completely and he spent the
all on you think that's what Chris said
probably that's what Chris said good for
him
man all right I'm not I'm not doing
weights nothing that one boom boom boom
you going the full randomiz one VI all
righty smack I like it I like
it look like pizza rolls
nice choice anyone else no I think
that's it oh Zachary you want to do it
Qui Rapid Fire get you some healing
crystals Zach you need them love the's
also surrounded by Boba I know there's
so much Boba Guys help Zach out he he
needs he needs a good healing Crystal
give him a good
one well we have yet to give our gifts
to all the crew members and everybody
got make sure he picks a good one you
know we we want good for and you have
the Halloween Zach what you have
Halloween nail polish on man yeah wow
but but that is not felt the Halloween
spirit this year at all nobody has
nobody what I'm saying dud neighborhood
used to go crazy all the houses we know
that used to do no none it's gone gone
and I didn't feel like the feeling this
year at all and I drove to neighborhoods
I didn't what Ethan said I literally was
like you know I'm going to go drive to
the bougie and it was just Halloween is
all the time for me I don't know what
you guys are on with you Halloween is
360 days a year go ahead Zach all right
I want this
one I want this
one and I
want this fish looking one W looks like
a I got a good feeling about
that one good piing all right so
um to make sure all right so is that
everyone I think that's everyone we got
somebody Pi this one because it's not La
okay I was like shoot it's on its own So
the plan here is going to take you guys
a minute to saw those open I guess yeah
it'll take a minute they're just just
based on quantity yeah yeah if you hit
like a nice Jade stone is it does it
take a minute to get through it it takes
a bit longer it's a little bit longer it
was better for us to do it like just cut
them all once like away because you kind
of it's like a spoiler yeah I see I see
what do you guys think about rare or
Metals love it or leave
it depends on which one Cobalt is a rare
earth metal right love Cobalt we love
cobal love that one if it's pretty I
like it if it's colorful pretty cuz
those ones are hard to get right in ter
cuz I know there's like a massive demand
for them right now for the only crystals
I like to buy are ones that are either
going to be mined out soon or ones that
are already mined out and the ones that
I really like to hoard and just kind of
sit on is like I have a lot of Sleeping
Beauty torqu o like that is a very rare
uh Source torquoise um there there's no
more of it the longer you have it the
more it goes up in value lapis is
getting minded out lapis too and plasma
aot like we said there's only one
location for it a lot of the California
crystals like people in China they'll
pay a lot because they can't get it at
all there's no plasma a in China there's
no UV that's that's another thing is
that the value depends on how far away
you are from the source interesting
Sleeping Beauty turquoise that's a
beautiful name let me pull that up have
you guys heard about the
oh wow this is beautiful that is
beautiful you take a look at vanana
night banana Knight banana night with a
V banana B ban banana KN vanana Knight
oh vanana vanana
night
van
night here I got it
vanan why do they have to spell it like
that banad denight they got all crazy
names it's like Nickelodeon orange and
it little cool little squares and
they're so sparkly and they grow in that
shape and they're so cool that's awesome
I have so much of that why does it grow
in that crazy shape it's just the
molecular structure the lattice
structure there a lot of rocks comes in
different uh different shapes depending
on like the temperature and how long it
was growing for all different flavors
exactly wow that's awesome um have you
guys heard about their how they're
planning to go like on the bottom of the
ocean to get uh rare earth metals have
you heard about that I think I heard
about that and it's not really a good
idea you don't think it's a good idea I
don't think it's necessary telling out
the whole ocean unless isn't it like for
was it for precious stones or was it for
like batteries for phones it was for
battery metals because I well that
doesn't sound like a good idea letting
that get all loose in the ocean either
yeah I feel like that would well they
they'd be pick up like whole rocks off
the ocean floor they're still disturbing
all that oh yeah it would be it would be
ecologically I'd have to think long and
hard about that and get back to me to on
an answer about how that's going to
chain reaction effect yeah it is very
interesting because all the precious
earth metals seem to be located
in like uh Africa a lot of them are in
and they're being monop a lot of them
are being monopolized by China they own
it and so if China has like a stronghold
on all these precious or
Ral the value comes from processing and
who's processing China like these they
got the whole industry locked down oh
dude we got to get those we have to get
the precious we need the rare earth
metals you guys they just need to like
have a bunch we need
more we need all of it it's true all
right um so thank you guys we'll get
we'll let's get cutting we have cut and
we we can check in about halfway through
their cutting uh we have a camera down
there and a microphone and they should
be able to hear the show oh should we do
gifts before or after this we can do it
after okay yeah I one has to go in the
bridge so thank you uh thank you guys
we'll check in on them
sure that's very exciting very
exciting oh yeah I'm
thrilled now do you guys expect there's
a chance that you might be surprised by
what's inside any of these Stones some
of them sometimes sometimes they say
sometimes very good we'll get we let's
get cut all right so um as we get that
rolling free Congo I'm seeing absolutely
dude I'm going to win you think
so I'm so confident I think love might
have swooped in with some deadly picks
we'll see surprised by who picked you
know oh well I I want to hear your
analysis afterwards that'll be
great
um yeah Congo is like there's so much uh
like Cobalt
there and the people who live there get
zero benefit of their country being like
one of the most I think Congo actually
is might be one of
the
most resourcer countries in the world if
not the resource rich country in the
world and it's just being bought up by
America and China these these and
they're not benefiting from it
at all it's
horrible yeah it's like child work and
all that stuff too Emerald is saying
that the the working conditions are
horrid there as well quite sad I mean
there's no reason Congo should be like
Norway in terms of how rich it
is yeah but they're just getting
absolutely pillaged by show up harder
and America Democrat Republic Congo's
considered the world's richest country
in terms of wealth of Natural Resources
That's crazy dude crazy
don't you guys remember that movie The
Congo about the Apes and they found the
biggest diamond you what was that
movie wait wait what was that it was
called Congo that was sick
Bro did I with
Congo let's go to
Congo we we got a free
Congo eel pit we'll get to the eel pit
right now I want to talk about the Boba
we've we're having yeah we've having
Boba disputes as you guys
know I've been unsatisfied with the
bobas I've been getting I'm saying
they're too sweet usually or I just
downright don't like
it and so we got some
angry uh comments left on this thread
here on our
subreddit lots of bitterness being
expressed here the crew is doing Boba
wrong and I'm
mad uh okay so let's listen as a boba
loving Asian person oh so they have
credentials as
well as a boba loving Asian person I
have to say something I just watched off
the rails 91 and I'm getting annoyed
with the whole Boba debacle Ethan hates
Boba because they're doing a lot of
things wrong for starters the Boba Place
matters they are saying that you got to
go to the right Boba Place we've been
doing boba time and this person is
saying C or D tier Americanized Boba
trash mhm so to
they says to be fair it's not the worst
but it's definitely not the best okay
also you do not need to add Boba to your
drink but then it's not
Bobba then it's just
drink everyone I know refers to as Boba
colloquially but really we just mean the
desert the dessert drink okay with her
boob coming
out you can adjust the sweetness levels
because they don't use sweet anded
condensed milk only Thai or viit places
do that okay sweet Mill so where all my
flavors were set to
25 they say Z Ethan I go to a place
that's more authentic and get a simple
milk
tea so that's what I got here I believe
this is the simple this is the simple
milk tea right now don't let the amount
I've drank deceive you this is
sweet as
cream we did 25% on this right Sam
yeah it should say on the receipt as
well dude how can this be more sweet I
feel like it's capped out on sugar I
don't know mine is also pretty sweet I
got mine oh I got mine at 100% well wait
so we should we should say where this is
from Sam do me a favor uhuh put your
straw in here and taste it and then you
can tell me okay mine's 100% sweet but I
want it more sweet dude you're dude I
love your they I can hear them grilling
I can hear him stoning up that's
exciting they had a 120% sweetness on
place so Sam go ahead and taste this and
tell me is am I just sensitive or is
that a full sweet and
beverage Sam is going to try
it real experiment is going to be if Sam
has red eyes tomorrow what it's not it's
not even remotely sweet are you crazy I
think you're overly sensitive to
sweetness hold on hold on hold on hold
on what how can you say that's not sweet
this tastes like unsweet tea no stop I
swear it tastes like unsweet tea stop
can someone else someone else try
someone else try I'm
coming maybe if your if yours a sweeter
maybe it numbs your buds not you have
the same drink I do no I don't or Dan
does uh so this is uh Boba milk tea so
so tell me if it tastes the same this at
100 yeah this one's at 25
[Music]
apparently not that wa what
not here's do you do you think that the
balls themselves are too sweet you would
just like a chewy ball with absolutely
no taste hold on hold on hold on hold on
Dan say okay hold on put your balls in
my mouth it tastes the same in fact mine
tastes
sweeter you're Tri maybe there was maybe
there's some backup in the uh okay in
the straw it's very sweet then here's
the other thing people recommended this
one Sam what is this one that one is the
fruit tea with Ley jelly Sunrise fruit
tea
25% stop the sun stop the Sun from being
hot so I've tasted this
[Music]
one this one I will say it's not the
sweetness is good you don't like you
probably don't like the jelly pearls cuz
they are they are kind of weird I don't
like these pearls yeah mhm it's very
hard and also there's pulp in it you
should try mine who ask for pulp and
they tea no they get wild with
the drinks over there you got to expand
your if you're going to be moving to yon
you better you think they just drink
Boba and yon have no idea but you better
have learned d disrespect the the future
home of the je they blend up Jade drink
it Jade drink rocks that's true um who
said you wanted me to try yours Sam yeah
you want me to come there I I'll bring
it on did we did we mention the name of
this place you can so it's called
sunright Uh tea Studio it's in a te
Studio yeah it's in Little Tokyo here in
uh downtown LA so what does this one say
I had uh I've been here a few times
before I got to say red bean I don't I
don't want I don't want people get too
mad at me but I got to say I I live that
is vile dude that is so
gross ew dude it's like mashed up beans
in a damn milk drink that's crazy that's
that's crazy dud that's nuts no I
love red that's literally what it is
it's so good I love red bean anything
red bean I think it's so good dude
that's that's a wild drink I
didn't know I didn't know y'all was
doing all that there was um there's a
place that uh Ally really likes and she
got me a drink from there the other day
um apparently it's like super popular
there's always it's in L Tokyo and
there's always a line and they run out
of it so people like have to like go
early to get it cuz they only make a few
batches a day but it's a it's a drink
like this that has Mochi in it and it's
like it was the weirdest thing I've ever
had in my life it wasn't necessarily
good I'm it wasn't bad but the texture
is so bizarre cuz it's wet Mochi so it's
just this like glops of slime can you
can you try Sam's I'm curious what I
mean it's just nuts I've never imagined
drink like that in my whole
life it's
just it's like drinking a salad through
a straw almost that's that's kind of how
the Mochi one was cuz it just like you
had to suck really hard it wouldn't be
coming and then it would finally they
get sucked through the straw and just
just like goop just like hits the back
of your throat it was bizarre and suck
and suck so Dan is going to be hitting
this red bean
Boba is there boba in there or just red
bean Boba and red bean oh my
[Music]
god dude that's weird that is that's so
weird Sam like it's tolerable it's not
like gross but the texture is
bizarre I mean at least they're I mean
bread beans are healthy so it's like
dirt I love red bean I feel like there's
a mouth I have a mouthful of dirt right
now yeah not you ever had a red bean bun
so
delish that being said I listen I love
beans just not in my milk thank you oh
yeah brother but it's like a snack Sam I
mean you're getting some nutrition out
of that EXA you're chewing it really oh
Olivia's out not in this ew no that's
some alley core Ali would like that too
you guys can buy together on that one if
you don't like Pulp you won't like Bean
in your in your drink that's like
Pulp dude I'm drinking that's just
chunks of food I'm drinking the Creme
Brule Boba milk that sounds sweet
as hell there's like CR brui sweet
[Music]
gillet and it's so yummy I love love I
wish I could eat what you
eat to there was other there was other
like the uh Oreo brown sugar cookie
squirrel B see that's just that's just
crazy that's just too much yeah it's too
much so no cookies for you yeah but in
the in the end maybe I just don't like B
I was about to say there's people in the
chat that are like guys you got to take
them to this place listen this this is a
good place if he doesn't like this I
think it's just not for him and which is
okay it's fine I think it's it's just
too sweet my my original thesis is that
for the calories I'm consuming I'd
rather just have a sod pop sure you know
what I mean cuz how many calories you
think is in this whole thing man it's
got to be pushing like 400 maybe more
maybe five at most maybe that and that's
that's like a whole meal for me you know
right we asked uh people in this thread
where they're complaining that's where
we got this place and the drinks to
order so this is on right if you go down
here here Ian replied and people
responded with a bunch of them in fact
that top apply sun right that their
second answer that's that's where we
went that one popped up the most so
that was oh okay so that was a popular
suggestion popular suggestion so I think
you know I just I just it's just too
damn sweet and then this one I maybe I I
get this one more I I got to say the
recommendation on the whatever these
balls are on the bottom not my fave the
ly but this one is less sweet which I
appreciate right put your balls in my
mouth but it just it's not it
okay we got to the bottom of it just
give me a Coke Zero call it a
day Cofe not going to argue cut a nice
cup of coffee you know start you off
right did you have Boba Zack I think
he's he's a hater too oh you don't even
you won't even drink it hell no bro why
is that it's just extra calories you
just that's it that's it guys like us
Zach we're doing our best out here
exactly dude you know we you can't be
talking about Bobo you know don't you
can't introduce that element into my
life it's hard enough being me already
I'm sorry which one did you have Ethan
it was I had the uh milk tea okay that's
440 calories but it doesn't say the size
yeah I mean it's pretty big I don't
know what's the the the carbon sugar
count in that I'm curious dude carb is
73 73 sugar is 52 G dude holy
that's sick you got 25% of that too
that's not 100% bro you're better off
going to Starbucks and get like a
cappuccino or some it actually has
less
calories four how many did you say 450
440 and then this one is the
um this one is the uh sunright fruit tea
with Le
jelly I call this
capuccino I
don't it sounded like he said tapaco
which is funny cuz it is tapioca I call
Ito 270 calories that one's not as bad
so this one is more in the realm of
something that I would enjoy but even
270 for a drink is a lot for me but
what's the carbon sugar count
um carbs is 67 sugar is 53
D you guys want to hear loves 63 yeah
holy that's nuts bro 63 dude loves
has got to be nuts tell me about the
Creme Brule one I'm sorry 53 uh the
creme
brulee is 690 calories wa what yeah holy
dude 101 carb I'll take another
one how many how much sugar sugar 33
grams oh not a lot of sugar so you're
good you're good there love you I think
I'm drink drinking like U what's it
called half and half cuz it's thick wait
wait I think it's just there I think
it's just half the half with the cream
yeah they just cream dude 700 calories
wait I'm sorry Oreo or creme just the
regular crem cuz the Oreo one's eight
the Oreo creme bru 850 what yeah see
that's excessive bro that's like
three Big Macs right there bro dude I'm
sorry but that should be a we need
regulations we need the government to
step in uh-uh I came here for a re to
America to be able to drink a 700 calor
I'm saying we need to outlaw Boba I'm
just saying I'm with you on that Ethan
I've been fighting my weight my whole
life I did this just adds an element I
just do not need man uh it's fine the
kids one is only 670 calories which one
is that the kids Oreo Boba the kids one
yeah 670 700 that's three Big Macs bro
that's
insane don't you guys see this is a
problem we can't just walk around all
pretending like Boba is not ruining
Society guys we got to Outlaw
Boba calories are just a
number just like age yeah no no not like
age is the age of consent like calories
holy
I never
imagined dude sometimes you got to treat
your body like a temple sometimes you
got to treat it like a circus tent live
a little live a little bro sometimes you
got to treat it like a an ICP concert
yeah right no I do I do Kim but you're
you're you're a beautiful twink you have
a you're very skinny and you have a
great and you look great and healthy so
do you thank you Boba the Boba is not
going to put me on the right
path I'm an anti- Boby nah bro this is
freedom and a cough rather freedom in a
cup true that's true I'm seeing a
McDonald cheeks 800 calories too so
that's crazy it's the same so I
guess the question is is there a
perception of boba being not as bad as
like a milkshake you know I have a
feeling some people might think it's
like just like a wholesome tea drink
it's just tea yeah I'd say the the
people most of the time like i' I've
barely had it before moving out here
I've always Associated it with like more
of a a bougie thing I mean I guess I I
because it's more expensive and because
te's in the name I think people think
it's healthier than what it is the guy
in the red at thread called it a a
dessert drink though so so he knows cuz
he he understands what it is when you
think about it as a dessert drink then
it makes sense but I I see how popular
is people are drinking this for goddamn
for H to hydrate I seen them they're out
they're out there
man people know it's unhealthy they say
let's do a poll and guys I know that we
we've been having this Boba discussion
for a while but just vote with your with
your true heart here that makes s did
you did you perceive Boba as
being better for you than a milkshake I
don't know how to word
that
or should be do you think the perception
because they're all going to say that
they know what it is it's perception
it's perception yeah do you think the
perception is worse perception of boba
what the perception of boba what's worse
is the B no see that's a bad poll that's
a bad poll perspective we're just we're
getting set up for a b do you think
people know that boba's unhealthy yes or
no different perspectives did you know
that Boba do you think people do you
think people know that Boba is unhealthy
cuz our audience is educated they're
very smart they're very informed why
don't we ask did you think Boba was less
that's a good I'm okay with that
phraseology
mhm more sense for all the flag I get
for the bad polls you guys come up with
some bad polls man you guys are salad
over here going go ahead throw it up
throw that up yeah do do you think
people know that that Boba is unhealthy
fine yes or no yes or no it is what it
is people I know and when we say people
I mean just like you know some people
some people out there that just they
don't know I know let's see so this is
interesting oh God they're already
yelling holy though dude it's
almost 50/50 do you see boba's it's an
epidemic this is not a poll if people
think that is people if people think
that right it's a bad Paul no it's not
how are you going to find out if people
actually think that cuz our audience is
super smart a nuanced question that
we're throwing in a pole it's going to
be flawed sadly I'll say when I was
training for boxing I was trying to do a
better job what I was eating and I would
check calories more often but when it
came to Boba I just I didn't think it
was good but I didn't think it was as
bad as was that's that's my that's my
fear with the Boba with the Boba uh you
know conspiracy taking over also the
amount of sugar in it just makes you
feel like ass bro like you're
sluggish you're just ain't hating bro
mhm I truthfully really enjoy Boba and I
still do and I'm not not afraid to say
it yeah what Bo did you get I get a
regular milk tea Boba mhm you know
you're young you're in% sweet you got
your whole life ahead of you I'm thank
you you are young you're still you're
still allowed to do the whole play about
the sweets a sack this is why I think
you don't have the H you don't have the
Halloween spirit Zach what you don't
like sweet n I'm I'm salty so
Halloween isn't you aren't built for it
hold on this was glost over Zach hold up
your
hand no no no yeah yeah what's going on
here I mean this
guy it's it's a uh I'm trying I'm trying
try to get I respect that you got to be
the Halloween you want to M right all
right I see that I appreciate that nice
color ch and you know I I ordered a
burrito for lunch so like this is just
this is a second burrito though
a dude cuz if I if I just eat a burrito
probably won't finish it but let's say I
put down maybe even if I go hard on it
1,200 calories yeah
mhm you could go home have some fruit
have some light snacks and still end on
a weight loss day sure when you add the
Boba to the equation that just the math
goes out the window well also the
protein and the burrito too I I mean I
don't know what the protein count is in
Boba zero it's literally 100%
empty calories yeah but so is all
dessert so if you think of it dessert
and I you know I love
dessert I love dessert but because it's
a drink you're just less likely to get
full off of it I think that's the real
problem with it exactly thank you you
understand me I got you I hear them
grilling out there those stones are
being cut as we speak should we check in
on them would you like to I'll run down
okay we'll get set up for that I feel
like I'm in junin right now dude yunin
yeah junin why' you oh did you call it
junin cuz I'm moving the headquarters of
the Jewish people there no I didn't no
wait hold on we're moving to junin
this is our place
now that's crazy
minerales this is me and uh I forget his
name Hank Hank the
minerales new show do you think it's um
you think it's a little up in
this era with the rising anti-Semitism
to uh do a whole show lusting after
[Music]
gems
what are you trying to say
danad I'm just
saying unpack that for me there's a lot
that's anti-semitic D what the is
that
bro is it appropriate Maybe not maybe
not maybe where we shouldn't talk about
precious gems at a time like this
there's just too much happening in the
world getting our
guilt dude I love junin I love
junan we need to we just need to refocus
the Zionist energy a different part of
the world in yeah wouldn't that be cool
though
Zion wait did he say Zion what the
Z you didn't notice that the other day
how did you even do that why did you
that say I am but the way my
weird ass brain works is I heard Zion
and so like I put some like like
Ray game music on it and you got a Bob
Marley tune right there dude so I mean
no I hear it I know exactly I'm just
surprised you've thought of such a thing
z z it's kind of my job to think that
way
do we have that video of that white dude
going hard on the on the uh rust the
ratone just my
favorite no it was it was he was like an
English dude who was going crazy with
the like Jama and rap oh oraton I sent
it like two Just Dance
hole we'll look for it yeah now we got
all kinds of fun stuff to talk about
though let's see um I think we're ready
down there um if you guys can hear me
out of the speaker there can you give me
a thumbs up hold on hold on this is this
guy's my spirit animal
okay oh oh let me just play a second of
it dude I love this guy POV when you
find out you're half a percent
Jamaican I love that shut the
and this dude is BR
this this dude is M.R he's from uh
London he speaks with a proper British
accent then when
he I wonder out I wonder what Jamaicans
would say about it I saw him in the
studio with some Jamaican people so they
so he gets some rep he has some
reputation suck your Mama D his stinking
listen he's good turn
gymnastic
puss I mean he's good man oh
no that's so me right now
[Music]
no that's so me right now he's such a
Vibe right now bro H the Jamaican
dialect is so cool though like uh when
you hear people speaking like on this
how they talk yeah uh their whole
vernacular is so different and
interesting there's some like dialects
of English that are so different I
wonder which ones are the most like
different from what I'm used to as just
American English like Jamaican I guess
even like Irish uh when I I've been to
Scotland uh and some of the some people
there I genuinely was having a really
hard time those guys are those yeah the
Scottish it's borderline a different
language at that point same with
Jamaican they are they they the way that
they speak it they have all these
different words that they use and the
way they talk about things oh yeah oh
here there he is wait oh go ahead Zach I
was going to say it's not a dialect or a
form of language anymore but like Ela
Elizabethan like what the was that
you mean like old school English yeah
like Shakespeare I think that's
just how they talked back then yeah
idiots here here's my boy bombo clot is
that that's not like a racist thing
right can I I can say bombo clot right
uh I can't even I can't say bomble cloud
you can't Ethan what does it mean
kidding I don't what does it mean should
I not say it I don't know I think it's
something pretty nasty actually oh
really yeah oh tell me
what uh I don't want to be wrong so let
me look it up ask chat gbt dude chat gbt
got an update it's connected to the
internet dude and it will it'll
live fact check now okay so
Jamaican slaying equivalent to douchebag
or often used in expression
to uh interjection to express disgust or
dismay so I guess not okay so it's just
vulg the worst but yeah uh it's an oh
okay it's an insulting vulgarity that
literally refers to either a menstrual
pad or toilet paper
Jesus a bomba clot maxi pad all right so
here's our boy let's see what he has to
say I was born in like a sort of a
Countryside part of the UK and then I
grew up in London South wait wait wait
wait olly G
bro is a crazy
hold on hold on hold on yeah and um yeah
I reside back where where I where I was
where where I was born now in the
countryside so yeah I spent my whole
life in the UK born and raised cuz I'm
just trying to get to like how you're
even how how is your journey cuz you you
say you born and grw up in the
countryside but you're raised in London
so that's your connection to Jamaica oh
yeah this is sick no no not even um
V Elder sisters and brothers that was
kind of like my sister's quite a bit
older than me and from I was young from
I mean maybe even 9 10 years old um she
was with she was with a Jamaican guy so
Christmas times we used to go to
family's house
and it was it was like that from early
so family um then she got married MH and
and so on and yeah so he has a Jamaican
brother-in-law that sounds like it so he
get Jamaican at that he gets the path
that's how that works only Kingston it's
only Kingston only
Kingston all right so uh let's go check
in on the uh gem Cutters downstairs yeah
uh y'all
ready uh I think they're gonna show us
can you guys hear us yes we can hear you
are you getting the feed uh Ian yeah all
right they're ready here we are
Alleyway hey y'all the gem Cutters are
cutting they look awesome can they hear
us I can hear you well Ethan I can't
hear danwell okay so I'll just can can
they hear me you want to get it from
side yeah yeah there's a speaker down
there they're hearing okay so let's
let's just take a look at the the
progress so
far her her earbuds were in the
water that's I wonder what's the
strategy on that I just noticed that too
yeah I wonder is that part of the
process she said that is not part of the
strategy okay she just took them right
out of the water this one is your rock
which I thought was fitting because you
could to see it happen live um I kind of
picked it cuz I knew it would go fast
can you get closer up
ab okay so um I picked it cuz I knew it
would cut kind of fast then there's one
from
Dan Green Oh that's a winner on camera
um oh that's a winner for sure you wish
oh they're they're going to cut one open
for us live is that can you ask her how
come her headphones were in the water
they're ear Buffs they're they're just
for hearing so that you don't get ear
damag cuz it's so loud but is there a
strategy with keeping them in the water
or no adds
flavor it adds flavor it adds flavor oh
flavor all right am I good being this
close with no
glasses
okay yeah you're good ab wor yeah I'm
sure it's great she say she does it all
the time change my life
okay here we go oh that is like butter
see that's not a good sign I don't think
oh right it's supposed to be difficult
if it's cutting through that like butter
butter not looking good but who knows
maybe cut them off maybe it's
maybe I don't know what smooth looks
like maybe that wasn't that was too easy
so who's is this AB This Is My Rock we
want to do we want a drum roll yeah we
got the drum roll going okay here we go
oh it's pretty but I don't think it's
Jade what do you cool looking what do
you see inside of there emerald do you
want us to identify it for you now or we
go up yeah you can identify it all right
so that's basically pure graphite
graphite
graphite graphite with an s aite a ra
rafan knite this is a coolite site
there's no losers when you s theight
raite igar right or there's a whole
bunch they're all stuff that you can and
they're all really cool wait this isn't
mine this
is oh no breakfast burrito with
chicken only one person ordering this
psycho as
burrito that's okay all right now she
has Dan right now so people are saying
uh why isn't she using um gloves or
anything she explained earlier the blade
is actually not sharp you can you can
touch it uh she said because it just
uses water and friction to cut through
that which is pretty crazy that can go
through the Rockett much that's it I
hear him
cutting uh one sec I closed my document
which I often do here these days for
some
reason so in the meantime we've got
you're not there you're not there you're
not there I can't sleep when you're
nightmare it's a nightmare it's a
nightmare I can't
you're you're not there you're not
[Music]
there like
this
nightmare nightmare I can't see where I
am all right thank you
that
um I guess maybe we can hit the uh Rich
Lux vers Dan controversy
yes drama yeah this has been heating up
for a long long time you know and uh
it's finally come to a head we love Dan
been eating the office
alive um as you guys know Dan dressed up
as Rich Lux the queen on our Monday
Halloween special mhm and uh as we
expected it did provoke a violent
response from Rich he felt was up it was
upsetting to see I can't stand Dan so
here's here's uh Rich Lux you know what
guy from the video titled I'm
suing H Street podcast and Ethan Klein
and Dan they owe me at least
$5,000 okay I'd like to tell me how you
determined that number and then we can
talk about settlements but anyway here's
rich Lu
guys I've had it I've had it up to here
I'm suing A3 A3 Ethan
Klein and Dan the has had it
coming so here there I was all right
sitting at the Chinese
buffet with eugia Cooney okay hold on is
that a joke I kind of wondered that
no
[Music]
jeez I didn't mean that I think I think
it doesn't sound serious it sounds like
a joke I you see where you're coming
from but hey it well yeah okay so
anyway where were we Rich Lux says he's
at a Chinese buffet with Eugene
Cooney and
um we have some time stamps in the dock
if you want here all these messages on
my phone that Dan has impersonated
me and I'm like are you serious it's bad
enough that Dan is jealous of me but now
I just I can't stand Dan I can't stand
Dan oh no oh can't
standing and he's impersonating me this
video why did he record it from the H3
podcast mix stand recorded I can't
stand I can't stand in and he's
impersonating me what this
video the video has over like 500,000
views MH and doesn't even look nothing
like me I don't know the whole thing is
off the whole thing is off so decide so
so he's upset here I'll go to some of
the time STS and Dan you can decide if
you want to apologize or what when I'm
done here I and I'm a little shocked
that he's upset I I thought okay I had
to change mying him in a way thought it
would be an honor I thought so too but
maybe it's just because you've you have
had an ongoing feud maybe you've said
some unkind things about rich rich said
that I'm the queen and I've done nothing
wrong
uh he did say that I think he said that
you think you're the queen and you can
do nothing wrong dad is the queen
yeah Dan is the queen what happened to
that rich because Dan is so draining
been dried my battery out the other
guy's name they's been doing a pretty
good job he's not picking up the slack
Dan's been pushing the buttons you know
doing his whole thing doing it right
okay and then the other girl I forgot
her name well first of all AJ I think
his name is he dressed up like a Jedi
which to me it was giving like Hugh
Hefner Vibes like for a second I was
giving like Hugh Hefner I kind of know
what he means by you know why it's
because of all the chest I think mhm you
know we we had our troubles with Rich Lu
early on I I I love this guy man
he's awesome well the minute we
start liking him too much then he does
something to
piss we got to keep him like at a medium
length like one of those like nice like
professional toy lightsabers it is my
brothers and I accidentally broke it a
long time ago and then I just turned
into a prop so wait there's like a
significant amount of down votes 300
down votes on this what what what
happened let me go to the comments I
think they're probably
just they well they probably I don't
want to break the illusion but I'm
pretty sure he's joking and maybe they
thought he was real and they were
disappointed by the clickbait they only
care about the CL gosh so this comment
here says I love these comments from
people that don't get that rich is
joking mhm oh no oh maybe they thought
he maybe it's the opposite of what I
said maybe it's people that thought he
was serious and were upset but they were
coming for me they were standing up for
me okay oh well that's nice I can't even
ride Space Mountain without Dan ruining
my
vacation very good I do have a backup
one very good very good always have a
backup I'll tell you we bought the boys
these Lightsaber toys from Disneyland
all right this clip is too long Rich
you're you're stretching the fair use on
this one and then the other going sue
him thank you well I might I mean what
was the what was the point of that
lightsaber clip you could have cut that
earlier I think he's going through right
Olivia because Olivia time stamp he's
critiquing all of our costumes yes he's
going through and talking about us
Ethan's just criticizing the editing I'm
just saying who's suing who yeah mhm
other girl I forgot her name oh my God
you leave her name in the comments
Ballinger in the studio for a live
interview no
it's okay
it's not Colleen it's her Alter
Ego I think that this is the video that
would have went over well I think her
and her are sisters
all apologies I do kind of look like
yeah right yeah yeah no you pulled it
off definitely thank you thank you very
much it go hand inh handed me right
not not what I appreciate so you're
saying Rich you don't need Miranda plus
ukulele would have been forgiven I say
ukulele going on for a while we we're
going to have to talk about fair use
St this is
upsetting plus Miranda what you are
stealing my
content made more sense to my
eyes not a good I think Colleen should
have existed crazy response what the
I'm so long I four three times wrong
it's bringing people it's bringing
people it's bringing people this is just
Why don't you just call this here uh H3
podcast
re-uploaded that's what I can she needs
recognition she's one of those people
that you really don't really notice
until they just snipe you you don't
underestimate people like that her you
don't want let me tell you what I've
been watching A3 A3 for a long time I'm
like the 158,000 subscriber member
subscriber and I just want to say this
the coverage on Colleen Ballinger huge I
mean amazing when she put up the power
point and went list by list it was no
stone unturned very nice and that's what
I'm saying you wouldn't expect it she's
a little sneaky snake snipe don't not
underestimate her now Ethan Klein the
skinny Legend oh was he look like was a
SpongeBob I was shocked and of course
you can't say nothing wrong about he is
a queen too she was cool now here's the
mistake cuz I've watched the podcast
unlike some people who claim they do but
they really don't I've watched oh that's
a call out wait he actually must I think
he actually is a big time fan mhm oh
Rich ripx rip
Lux podcast and honestly the biggest
mistake that Ethan Klein made this week
was and he admitted it and I don't know
I don't know why he did it the video was
called being chased by Myers or
something like that first of all all
right oh my god dude there's actually a
[Laughter]
resemblance awesome I'll take it when
Falls besides him being a creep well you
know we're not saying you did what he
did right but the robe you should adopt
the look so wait he's calling me out
okay let's I'll I'll listen to you yeah
I'll hear you out
he said Ethan Klein said and this is
where I have an issue with Ethan and a
lot of people behind the scenes say
similar things the thing was Ethan Klein
said that he was going to title the
video interview with Colleen
Ballinger girl if he would have made
that the title of the
video you think so see that was a whole
internal I I said it I said and you know
what he predicted he said something like
and Dan talked him out of it that's
exactly what happened that's what
happened so me ab and love colluded to
cook up the dumbest clickbait title I
made the thumnail was Colleen Ballinger
is in the studio for an
interview and then we got pushed back
from Dan who said um yeah we here's the
ti
thumbnail we had it in the
chamber so happy to be here I was like
it's the one time of year we could use
it let's do it the little Halloween
trick
we go back and change Monday's episode
to this I I'm happy with how it turned
out okay you know all right but I don't
know you know it's easy to say oh that
would have crushed but like if people
were clicking it for That interview do
you think they would have stuck around
that's the weird thing about our show
they do stay this is the thing I think I
think our audience knows that we meme on
on this at this point like on title and
thumbnail we talk about it a lot on the
show so it's sort of just like a meme
most people understand that and then new
people they'll bring them over and half
the people be pissed and the other half
be oh what what's going on this
show we'll get him next
time we haven't done it in a while
although the thumbnail with my SpongeBob
look was pretty cool well I said Olivia
can just come in another day with that
costume on and we can just we can do
that any day keep it in our back pocket
girl so if you see that thumbnail please
still click it in case of emergency
break that glass and I'll put on the red
lips all right in case you guys see that
on Friday definitely it was Colleen
who's going to be here I just contacted
her and she's coming on Friday
yeah
unrelated million views like that real
quick girl clock that the house clock it
the house it would have been an easy
million views I don't know why he did it
Ethan Klein is slipping Dan is letting
Ethan Klein slip I I would if I was
there I would have change the title
Colleen interview with Colleen bound
question mark question mark and then
it's because when the camera turned to
her I thought it was Colleen the
impressive
impersonation was on like Dan and cuz
Dan can do no wrong and um the AJ guy
dressed up at the Jedi that was spot on
the only one who missed the mark for me
was e Klein because he should have tled
the video colen baller interview and
matter of fact you can still do it you
can all right we got to get rich on the
phone I think I think it's time we got
to talk to him really yeah I think it's
time to bring him into the universe okay
I think we need to roll out the red
carpet full interview I don't want them
in the studio we'll start with the phone
call I mean no listen no offense the
thing is when you bring someone in a
studio you're stuck with them for a
whole episode and so I like to start
with the phone call cuz I can basically
I can exit that when I want to right and
uh I kind of sometimes when I get stuck
in the studio with someone I just it
turns into a hell cuz like I I'm just
stuck there and I don't want to talk to
them anymore um speaking of getting
people on the phone here actually let me
just type it
so I can't breathe when you're not here
you're not
[Music]
here oh c man wants to call in just
randomly okay it let's talk to C
man it's a rare it's a rare pleasure oh
my
God C man messaged emailed us what was
it on Monday he emailed on Monday uh I
think I assume it's somehow got to him
that we were talking about feet finder
okay cuz remember they even had a
section with the Barefoot stuff so
somehow that M unless it's just a crazy
Cosmic coincidence that he uh well let's
find out come pedal pumping is what it's
called all right I I'll see if I'll see
if he's uh CU this this was actually
from a few EMA if you can cuz I said do
I think I can get on today at 600 p.m.
New York time this is way after the show
ended by the way 6 6 p.m. New York time
or 6:30 New York time no this is the new
email from today you want me to read the
other email I got last one yeah the
other one I
got
uh okay let me read the this one hey
when is a good time to be on again I can
today if needed at 6 p.m. or so my time
that was just kind of like out of the
blue he sent that the reason I'm
giggling is I just noticed my previous
email from
him is just I would like to know about
Andrew Tate's feet
so we'll talk context at all oh my God
here let me make some notes cuz I don't
want to for know what he thinks about
Andrew Tate's feet
stat stat well he was asking us it's
like why are you asking us I'm you know
what I'll Supply the I'm going to get
the info for him hold on okay so I got
to I got to use the bathroom so let's
get let's talk to Cam man uh you know
sometimes Mercury's in retrograde and
the planet's align and today's one of
those days yeah iess kind of like a
he's a unicorn it's hard to get a hold
of C so when he he comes when he's ready
yeah he comes on his turn well he's
going to be like oh I can't call in
today sorry I can call in two weeks from
the next uh full moon yeah he has done
that all right I'll be right
back all right I'm shooting off an email
to the C man right now I just received
word from the Jade gang that they're
almost done so we should have a jade
reveal of everyone real
soon that's all I got to say that's
great hope you're having a wonderful
Wednesday uh thanks you too
cam you too Cameron um thanks I wanted
to say uh there were several members of
the audience I forget if it was like a
week or two ago there was a super
chatter um that was strongly encouraging
me to go play the game cyberp Punk
because I had totally uh skipped that
when it came out cuz it was such a
disaster um so I got it this last
weekend I got to say I'm having a what
fun with it this they fixed that
go dude yeah wait did you
play it I didn't but when you when you
vouch for something like that I'm like
all right it's good yeah I I can
definitely recommend it um I've been
having a real good time with it it was
just you remember what a disaster it was
it was like buggy ass mess and
everything but there's like a bunch of
fixes have come along and it's running
super smooth on my computer I don't have
your your computer is more powerful than
mine AB so you shouldn't have any issue
well it was built by a wizard that's
right that's right Dan built my PC King
the new uh South Park episode talks
about a balers Gate 3 wait does it
really yeah it's it's a really funny
epod oh I'm going have to check
that I haven't watched a new episode of
South Park since like 2016 you're going
to want to watch this one okay oh all
right um on the note of thanking the
audience for recommendations thank you
guys uh everyone who recommended uh
options for me I'm still going through
them we're using T-Mobile internet right
now and so far it's good for like just
using like the internet for work or for
streaming like uh to Netflix or watching
Netflix but yeah I haven't tested its
full ability I think I need something a
little stronger but so far so good not
as bad as I thought sweet that's great
new thank you guys yeah since we're
talking about video games video games I
have something cool to announce I opened
a Sian tiger at the office the other day
dude this guy lost his he was
having a heart attack yeah I've never
seen him like oh my God he's like
nothing's wrong yeah I got so scared
I've never seen Olivia that scar she
looked over like whoa whoa Whata I was
like no no something good just happened
I opened a swift soan tiger so and you
explained this to us but this was a
mount in World of Warcraft that was
taken out of the game over a decade ago
oh yeah and it's like super rare right
yeah you can only get it from black
auction box since you were a little boy
you've been trying to get yeah yeah yeah
this is like a probably the rarest M
look at the uh chat real quick asking
something did you say that like every
day you would check for one and you
would never had it and like that morning
it was that was the
day sorry what was that I was responding
oh you said that every morning you would
check for one right yeah so every every
morning when I come to the office I buy
a block black auction house box before
work what's a black auction house box in
World of Warcraft and yes you still
you're an active wow player no I only
collect things now playle things we were
explaining the other day at the office
he opened one of those and got like a a
juicer mager item you said it thousands
of dollars it would probably be $2,000
yeah yeah is it a mount yeah it's like
an old Mount that you can't get anymore
s gr wait I thought it was like 10 grand
dude not 10 grand that's what I thought
at first but more like you you said it's
like 10 grand and then we were like
where and you were like in the game
you're you're like I'd have to sell my
account in order to get that yeah you
can't get that actually
right um anyhow by the way we never
talked about the Halloween episode but
the Michael Myers part was was a total
hit and uh I feel
like special recognition to Lena who was
straight out of a slasher film watching
her struggle through the door as closed
in on her was really something it was
fun it was scary though wasn't it oh
very it it it's in tense man you have
someone coming at you like that oh
speaking of which since we're on the
topic h Michael Myers let me
pull this up oh right right right
right right right right right hold on
here someone put this together on the
subreddit thank
you first of all thank you to tall
skeleton
now I had accused Michael of rigging
this
because it seemed to me clearly he
was going way faster for
some and way slower for others so this
person timed how long it took him to get
to the door as you can see Zach he gave
12 seconds
to 12 seconds Zach got interesting
Olivia got almost 12 Sam got nine I'm
just going to round up or round down
nine love got nine Ela got seven now
hold the phone though keep going
look at me I was by far the Le the least
or I guess tied with Cam yeah 6.7
seconds and I was faster than you too
and did you didn't survive the first
round did you no we both got out how can
you you don't you can't open the door in
three seconds yeah almost two times as
much in the Dan of course who won
basically got 10 whole seconds
now you're I want to talk about what
you're talking about it is important but
can I just draw attention to the left
column I got to that door in 3 seconds
I'm oh dude I'm so fast
dude wait hold on so fast you
got the fastest time I am fast as
I've tried to explain this it's official
Dan is fast as yeah wow impressive
well what was your there's a part two of
your speeds look into but there was a
real issue here and Zach I don't I'm not
want to point fingers but you got the
most time by far do you have a
relationship with the the guy who was in
the Michel I was speaking to Michael
again don't know who the he is um
he was getting very claustrophobic and
felt dizzy and I felt like that's why he
was hering it up you tell him if I see
him I'm G to stab him if you
ever see Michael Myers he hold
on he was just trying to get on with it
so he could leave not leave I think he
really wanted to take the mask off he
getting like kind of couldn't I don't
want to say he couldn't breathe but he
he doesn't do well with like um can't I
bre is a nightmare it's it must have
been a nightmare
nightmare okay so he was he was flushed
be suffocating I guess I wasn't
suffocating I he just doesn't he he uh
he don't like it he didn't he didn't dig
that it was very uh claustrophobic I
guess what's I guess that explains it
because I kept being like Michael slow
down then he would run again he
was disoriented I think to
oh my God I was like is he I should
have laugh poor serial killer dude they
have feelings too cam Michael Myers is
having a having a panic
attack too tight kind of funny so yeah I
mean I got Mega I feel like you and
I both buddy there's weights and fish
cam yeah he didn't go he he went the
fastest in the first round for the both
of us he didn't go that fast again after
that dude weights and fish we got
well let's see round two did he slow
back down so round two again Zack your
claim doesn't make sense because def
look at this his times is all over the
place it's all over Zach got 7.7 seconds
Olivia got 11 seconds
wow although Fast Times here Olivia
actually 3.4 seconds love almost 3
seconds flat hold
on 2.7 seconds he was juicy I'm I'm
quick he's fast as too hold on Dan
did three seconds so AB has a world
record if you look at the first one
though ultimately Dan got first and I
got second and that was the uh the same
order of our speed for round one right
so some indication Dan got 11 seconds on
the second round wow same with AB I mean
come on you guys don't even know what a
7sec round feels like uhuh there's
weights and
fish round
three he slowed it down a little bit
here it seems like although not a
lot this one is this one isn't that bad
it all it's all within like two pretty
consistent yeah I think he was getting a
gauge for
it he was what he was he wasn't you know
he needed more rehearsal you exactly he
need more rehearsal time to get the he
said he was not feeling well under that
math didn't know that bad could have
helped him out if he was I think he was
trying to be a team player and yeah um
well thank you I appreciate that I mean
thanks Michael wasn't on my team clearly
but
on but Dan did have the fastest run in
the round three so what happened AB you
you you went from 2.7 to 3.6 wow it's a
full second I I had this problem I used
to do it in track too where I kind of
skip in the beginning I don't know why I
don't know if that has to do with it but
I kind of do a little skip before I run
you can't launch straight into I can't
launch yeah interesting well there it is
uh it was rigged it was rigged okay well
then I won't I won't Lord my victory
over you too much no you still won Dan
that's awesome I understand the
Integrity of the contest it matters Dan
is the queen Dan is it matters on that
note I just want to say Lena actually
she didn't see it till it too late but
she got an offer to be a voice actress
in a like Michael Myers video game Queen
what based on the episode we had no no
not based on the episode like previously
and she didn't see until like months
later and it was too late how did they
find her yeah there's a um a Halloween
game and I played it and they saw and
they wanted me to voice over a female
character for their next game oh they
saw you like playing the game and
freaking the out and I thought I
couldn't even finish it it was so scary
wait that's so you have that's so sick
so did you miss your your opportunity I
did because I went to like my YouTube
email which I don't check as much and so
I missed it by the time I emailed them
back and they said if they ever make
another one they'll reach back out
really there it is we need Lena back in
that game
people um Reddit is saying we did in we
did that one the Boba new button stats
are
in okay well this is fantastic someone's
crunching the numbers on our button
usage beep beep beep um here we have by
show off the rails H3 TV and after dark
uh in their blue green and red minute
mark Mark
okay and then here it says but how many
buttons
no that many smash that
button nine buttons in a
week or is that every 10 nine buttons in
10 episodes that's pretty
gnarly really a month I love these stats
I find them so interesting well no
they're
minutes the time of on the left the
buttons minute and
buttons so well then nine buttons in
what one episode there's no way no in at
that time stamp at that time stamp and
all podcast since we got the bottom oh I
see that's when you're hot so that's
when goes down around 100 minutes
yeah yeah and zero after that apparently
I go hot and then I cool off 120 to 130
nothing demons out we're gonna have to
uh address that
but there it is guys the button data is
in total buttons per show H3 TV is in
the
lead um but pretty pretty close just
little less with Eli right right she
does have a calming effect on
me new chiropractor joins the
battle oh have you seen this yet I did
yeah I watched it oh it's so
good I
look away if you're sensitive to this
kind of
stuff it was
removed oh I click on the the link below
the what the f Reddit right there I
wonder why it was removed cuz this this
is chiropractor torture is on theme this
is my
but okay I trust our
mods anyway here it
is
wait wait I skipped forward a little bit
Zack this is good sound material and
apologies just turn off your earbuds if
uh for the next
minute he was about to hit him again as
he was curled
up so is this guy a is he consider
himself a chiropractor or like
a torture was an art form back in the
medieval days they had you know that was
their
job oh my
God bro you just punched him in the back
man my God he's in like Agony no no no
don't don't have have a
heart please
man don't show some
mercy why are you doing this
dude
what are you doing you're just you're
beating this man up he's just hitting
him on hold no mercy there's
no calculation here he is just
indiscriminately punching his
back you just wouldn't understand you
don't speak to ghosts
true he is like praying as he's doing
it dude what is the a killer what is
no that one was good he feels good wait
he just adjusted his dick hold on I
think he got turned on from that swear
to God watch his watch his belt line
here after he hits him look at that he
just he just touched himself no okay I
don't think so the doctor didn't it look
like it
here
no oh you you say no you spotted it it
looked like he touched himself yeah that
looks a little bit so is this okay
interesting that does add an interesting
layer to
everything oh you feel so relaxed feel
rejuvenated I love the car man it
loosens me up just punch him in the gut
man it's okay guys he's wearing scrubs
he's yeah he's a professional yeah oh
okay okay okay is is he wearing he must
be wearing something like really hard
that inflicts a lot more pain than a
normal punch whatever's around his wrist
or the guy has like a serious back
injury it must be a combo what if he has
like a broken back and this guy's just
pounding his back that's crazy he does
have a broken back and it's a result of
this man and it's just a vicious cycle
and it just keeps going where's no pain
Lorraine man she wouldn't be making this
much pee she'd be having no problem no
she say quiet you look like a baby dude
she's com she's
[Music]
comest no why twice double why twice
combo what a combo move this so
scary this guy's done no more oh this
poor
guy there's got to be a better way
that's his special right there that's
his finishing move
yeah here's my finishing move
fatality he asked me to turn over while
he slipped the condom on himself dude
okay maybe I've seen enough of the um
the Russian variety of just punching
people in the back okay you sure I'm not
sure get over here believe this guy was
AR but at a c at a certain point I feel
like maybe I just am starting to feel
bad for these
people you know well let's see what the
comments are in WTF oh that guy doesn't
work here your chiropractor will be here
shortly that's very funny thank you Sam
he says at one point he goes uh what me
which I I I think that's what he said
which means don't say a word now I don't
know if he was saying it like just shut
your mouth or if he was saying it like
don't talk while I'm doing this he says
don't both are bad yeah well I mean
unless he was saying it like because as
he's doing it speaking could make it uh
worse I don't know oh which is why I
punched him in the back when he was
streaming
right holy
smokes I'll just stick to Archie my back
over a
log
yeah there it is there it is chiropracty
uh triggered people can you're welcome
back now you can come back and into the
room
yeah
um okay so this is interesting this guy
Nick Ms you know this guy right love
because you're a gamer what's his story
um I think he moved man didn't he get
like a cake thing yeah he he he's
initially I believe he's from Michigan
uh he was a Call of Duty streamer and he
got a deal with kick and uh he moved
he's moving out of the US I believe so
that he could uh do the gambling portion
of that deal that's
awesome he was a well respected like
gamer just a couple years ago yeah or a
year ago but now he's well the reason I
bring it up is because um this guy made
a statement about um was it the
Starfield yes so you know the
Starfield uh pronouns controversy that
they they asked at the beginning of the
game what gender you want your character
to be pronouns and so this guy was
railing he says could you pull it up I
mean he says something like leave the
kids alone uh well I think you might be
confusing the two controversies this you
remember earlier this year there was
like a big brawl that broke out at a uh
Pride protest or it was it was over in
uh Glendale uh near La here and he had
replied to somebody pride month saying
let people love who they love and live
your own life uh with they should leave
little children alone that's the real
issue and um he had his skin 990,000
likes right and remember he he had a
skin in Call of Duty dedicated to him
and Call of Duty pulled it uh after this
controversy and kind of like a whole
thing of dut's part yeah like so yeah
that was the last time he was on our
radar I think okay so this guy he wants
to protect the kids
against gay people just not gambling
yeah that's gambling is cool gay people
is bad here take a look take a listen
the chat the first question I've been
seeing is like yo Nick are you going to
do gambling
streams say it season yeah yes we we are
do we're going to do gam we're we're not
going to do a ton but we're going
to do some gambling for sure it's it's
part of the contract you know um with
that being said part of the contract I
love how he tries to be
like it's almost like he's like yeah
we're going to get him a little bit but
anyway he's he's obviously uh ashamed in
a I think there's a sense of Shame yeah
for sure and a sense of sellout
hackery uh that he re he
acknowledges yeah I got it now we should
acknowledge that we are gambling here on
stream today very true so let's not be
hypocritic well okay but
ours for the
record is beautiful precious tangible
stones made of Jade oh yeah beautiful
this man is gambling crypto okay so if
you got gold coins and and you want
to gamble I'm cool with that gambling
Joy here in the studio although to be
fair gambling in person is a lot
different than crypto casinos where they
don't even barely verify your age or
identity dude he's just also we're not
really gambling right he's just trying
to protect the kids guys that's it this
is to protect the kids guys no books but
gambling's okay yeah God bless yo this
burrito's crazy
good you guys try it that's really
good
um let's
finish uh we we got another place cuz
you can't do it in America you you have
to go somewhere else so we went
somewhere else and we got another place
wow what a scumbag this man just
sold out so hard he cares about the kids
it's you know we got to keep keep leave
the kids
alone anyway guys uh my signup bonus is
$100 free with a $200
deposit guess what we don't even need
your identity all you need to own is
crypto
MH very good I he must got a bag I mean
for sure 100% yeah multiple multiple
millions does he have a lot of viewers
when he streams he's very very popular
but I'm sure on those platforms he's a
fraction of what he usually was what are
we talking like 10 20 30,000 more man I
wish I knew exactly but definitely over
10 so you're saying that I could get I
could probably get such a fat contract
from K yeah for sure yeah oh yeah they
would they would probably pay more than
anyone dude hell yeah the you're the
Harvey Dent to kick you know I'll split
it if they if they want to give us like
I don't know they gave xqc 100 million
apparently allegedly I mean I'm not I'm
not as worth as much as him but maybe 50
million I I disagree I think because
everyone's like of course xqc would go
over but
you they made you uh Harvey D too face
see he's not that bad uh so apparently
he's live right now with 8,000 people
watching and like listen that's a lot of
people but at the same time this guy's
getting paid millions of dollars and
he's relocating his life that's
how worth it is for him to sell gambling
to his 8,000 concurrent viewers man kick
is I hope there's a documentary
about all this
huge shady ass business going down here
I'm
still kind of shocked that there has not
like New York Times or
you know Wall Street Journal or
something hasn't done like a deep dive
on this whole C crypto gambling thing so
true and like feel like it's Prime for
that I'm deep on stake has gone so
mainstream they've got Drake they're
sponsoring commercials
right that would be crazy if stake is
what pulled down Drake after such a
successful career if it was stake that
took him down Drake I think Drake will
maybe he'll look bad but I don't think
he'll be liable for much all right he'll
be fine you know what I mean
he's just a paid representative as far
as I
know um so shout out to Nick M who cares
about kids uh leave them alone he says
leave them
alone let them gamble in peace let Gaye
get out of here and let the kids gamble
please how can you have any pudding if
you don't eat your meat so
true so true I didn't hear you he's
making a little Pink Floyd uh how you
going to eat your peas if you don't have
your pudding how are you going to eat
your pudding if you don't eat your meat
exactly how how it's impossible the most
impossible so the stone folks are uh
setting back up yeah we're just about
ready for the big reveal here I see some
gorgeous cut open Stones there
unbelievable I'm looking forward to
getting on
up uh but until
then Ronda santis got called out for his
hidden heels that's
good again no he got CAU out to his face
oh like some this dude um in your boots
the bipolar disorder
podcast and I I think it's kind of rude
to conjure
that I mean the BP
BPT podcast BPD yeah that's I mean
that's what it means that's good so it's
an inter in choice of course for and I I
don't think it's necessarily right to
you know conjure such a this this
condition that people live with but
that's his choice so he had Ronda STIs
on and he comes at him hard
about the boots heels I'm sure your
marketing team points out how they're
trying to troll you in the marketplace
okay I'm sure they're doing that can you
bring this one clip I know you were on
uh uh uh what do you call it on uh uh
what was it Bill Mah and Bill Mah talked
about the boots I've seen you walk with
these boots go and play this clip this
on Tik Tok went viral it doesn't have a
million views it doesn't have you know
10 million views this thing's got 1.2
million likes and and some people are
wondering H what are they I don't even I
haven't seen that what there's dude Ron
is look at this yeah right
he dude he is like having an an
existential panic attack right
now and he's Relentless too this guy
thought he was you know they're they're
out
guess it's a conservative dude there's
they've not shown this to you okay what
they're trying to say with this is that
in your boots you have heels what you
doing no no those are just standard off
the rack um lucazi um how tall are you
Governor how tall 511 okay
what look how tall he is shits
up poor guy I think he's actually like
five or something cuz based on 5 five
with a little attitude uhhuh this man
has 4 in cowboy buds okay why
don't you wear tennis shoes and dress
shoes uh I do wear tennis shoes when I
work out yeah you do okay I got a gift
for you I'd love for you to wear okay
ice shop at
ferl this is ruthless isn't it this is
brutal yo homie pulling out the
farra he's he literally said put these
on right now you know I'm not the
biggest fan of this guy but I have to
give massive props for him to have the
balls to just call him out to his face
like this this I wonder if he knows that
he was going so hard on him I don't
think so it seems like he's trying to do
it in somewhat of a friendly way but I
don't know if he actually is friendly or
if he's just softening the blow by being
kind of friendly about it
hilarious though Ronnie boy is having a
bad time right now at least he's keeping
his chin up S up straight look how look
his chin is up
yeah I don't accept gifts I can't accept
it I'm sorry put here and far can get a
nice sponsorship and then if you wear it
you faed I know no but here's the thing
I mean by the way he was we him it he
was so quick like I can't accept those I
can't accept gifts is that true by the
way oh if it's yeah if he's campaigning
there's the rules around gifts are very
very strict cuz it can be considered a
donation to The Campaign like bribing
him yeah and when he drops out he can
get a nice pair of shoes you
know FGL okay
and I don't accept gifts I can't accept
it I totally get I'm going to put it
here and far can get a nice sponsorship
and then if you wear it you fair I know
what that he goes from smiling to like
lizard like watch this get a nice
sponsorship and then if you wear it you
Fe it I know
dropped was that he does that a lot
we've seen other clips of him he has
this bizarre I don't he's a weirdo he's
just a weirdo it happened right before
sponsorship his chin was coming out too
he was doing it right before this moment
as well he's trying to hold something
back okay if you wear you feed I know
but here's the thing I mean I think with
just how politics works is um you know
Yogi Bara when he was um uh in the
Yankees they said you know Yogi he
doesn't look like a Yankee you know he
doesn't do this and Yogi's basically
like okay you know if if you say I'm
ugly that's fine but you know you don't
hit a baseball with your face and so
what we're doing is you know really I
think doing the the issues the
leadership let's not the are you
talking about he's saying that listen
I'm here to govern not talk about me
wearing foreign shills oh that's not
what I I thought he was saying like like
if you look at history all presidents
are tall and like leadership I don't
know I thought he was saying like we're
filling the role but I guess I was
looking too deep yeah you're giving him
way too much credit hold on let me go
back that I'm going to put it here and
far can get a nice sponsorship and then
if you wear it you faed I know no but
here's the thing I mean I think with
just how politics works is um you know
Yogi Bara when he was um uh in the
Yankees they said you know Yogi he
doesn't look like a Yankee you know he
doesn't do this and Yogi's basic so I
guess people thought he was ugly I don't
know that means was he a beast I I don't
know what he looks like a picture we be
like dude that guy's busted as
hell he doesn't look like a
Yankee he's doesn't seem that busted at
all yeah he's
actually looks handsome why he's a
little goofy looking but it's not not
out of the ordinary yeah I mean his name
is yogie bear that is weird so the the
cartoon character was a play on him not
the other one okay okay so that makes
more sense that makes
sense like okay you know if if you say
I'm ugly that's fine but you know you
don't hit a baseball with your face and
so what we're doing is you know really I
think doing the the issues the
leadership people that are poking at you
for different things that's fine but
ultimately that is not I think it's a
sign of
strength yeah it's a sign of Str lives
he's like listen guys I'm not going to
my feet aren't going to be the president
I'm the president let's focus on what
what matters here you
know very
good we love it good pretty good we
absolutely love it don't we all right um
should we do the big reveal now are they
ready are they here I think so oh yeah
if we're if they're waiting for us then
yeah for
[Music]
sure
welcome back
[Applause]
everybody oh yeah that makes
sense
um one
[Music]
moment all right how was The Cutting
process guys it was faster than expected
to be honest really well I thought it
was going to take a lot longer but um
our saw I was just underestimating it
because it's not even really supposed to
be meant for well people so many people
in the hobby use the same saw it's just
a tile saw with an agot cutter blade
works fine and so the only thing we had
trouble with was one of the big ones and
uh yours yours was the hard the one that
we watched not the one you watched oh
there didn't even harder one oh
interesting and so were you able to were
you able to cut them all open yes okay
there was one where we cut halfway
through realized it would take too long
to keep going so we cut in from the side
and got a corner cut so it's kind of
cool okay we got some of these are going
to be in little little cake slices
little pizza slices so here's what I
think we how we should do this let's go
person by person and then we can see how
well each person has picked okay sounds
good
oh I think they can do it you don't need
to be there yeah and if we can is there
some way we can calculate the value you
guys can just throw something out there
yeah we can tell what R yeah yeah hell
yeah so can someone keep count of the uh
of the value
here oh is it the camera's
dead that we swap
batteries so were you guys surprised by
any of the stones cut open there were a
couple where I didn't think there'd be
Jade and there was Jade so there were a
little bit more winners than I thought
about three
oh exciting
thrilling all right so let's begin you
guys can start is can someone keep count
you got it
okay
uh all right where are you guys
from um well I mean we're all from
Southern California these two are from
Orange County and I'm from uh the valley
oh okay sweet well we recently moved AIT
we moved a little bit above uh just like
in the mountains above LA because we
wanted a little I'm starting a mini Farm
oh nice mhm the I'm in school for
science so I live in St Louis abiso
right now oh great but I have a guest
house on my Creek and she's going to
live in it in two years so we're
Unstoppable Duo also to answer your uh
question about the mining of up bottom
of the ocean um yeah it's that's bad
it's bad yeah don't do you looked into
it no I looked into it to like double
check and know exactly what's wrong and
yeah it's the thing about like
with an ecosystem is that you do one
thing and it just has a chain reaction
effect on everything surrounding it so
taking away the Precious Minerals that's
already Dru destroying and disturbing
the habitat of the organisms that are
there and then it's going to kick up
silt and sediment and a lot of the
carbon in our Earth in Earth is like
trapped in the ocean are you so smart
you don't want to up you don't want
to bring carbon from the ocean to the
surface that's like the worst thing you
could do we already our planet is
already like on fire how does the
carbon what's the process of the carbon
leaving the ocean and entering the
atmosphere from mining rocks so you just
kind a lot of it is trapped like at the
very bottom of the ocean like really
deep so you think it's just bubbles well
it's that but it's also you're you're
stirring up you're like you're
kicking things up even if you're just
going down there and picking things up
um the air pollution for the fish will
be bad bad well yeah that's it's going
to it's it's going to um Vis visually
cause a lot of light pollution um and
that's going to oh with the ocean they
with the ocean so even though it's at
the very bottom uh the organisms that
live there they're going to get like
suffocated I have a Counterpoint what
about t Tesla stock
value scientists didn't consider that
point yeah wasn't Tak most of them say
uh most of them say shut the up but
all right so well because it's so
destructive you can pretty much count on
it happening so we look unfortunately
yeah I don't think that uh scientists
are going to be able to stop this one
guys could you I wonder if you can make
an argument that if you're just
obviously ecologically it's going to be
really bad for the animals that live
there but maybe you can make an argument
that because of we're creating these uh
green green uh batteries that can you
know uh Power electric big electric
things like cars machines even airplanes
think it's like a tradeoff at that point
cuz then like that is an argument that
people are making but the thing is the
train thing one or a bunch cuz
eventually like pollution is going to
it's already killing a lot of people
because of just climate change and I and
then it's only hurting people who aren't
the people who can buy Teslas so it it's
just arum too it is but part of the
problem is that deep ocean is not very
well understood by anybody and the
problem is that if got to find another
way to make batteries if you with
it and it does something really bad
there's nothing you can do to fix that
right it's like you're it's a stack of
Cs must around like jeng right yeah you
might be able to do it and it'll have
liit limited effects on us but you might
take that block out and the whole thing
comes crashing down so it's a really
risky game every time humans interfere
with nature something goes wrong like
Hawaii and the the Mongoose thing and
then the mustard all in California was
supposed to be it was supposed to be
like in a big long line between all of
the missions to be like a big Golden
Trail but that just spread everywhere I
mean you go anywhere in California every
corner and there's mustard and it's not
supposed to be here and it is not native
and it is choking out native plants so
many of the plants that we have all over
the place are invasive and should not
be in the wild west all right
there it is there it is fun fact sorry
Ethan I I I want to also I don't know
much about um deep sea ecology or
anything what me personally really risk
what do you do with your time right but
I do know a little bit about duren's
folk who dug too deep in doom and they
Unleashed a demon of Shadow and Flame
called bog we don't want that to happen
that ended up being the Doom
of at the same time the balog is what
caused gandal to ascend from metim yes
it is a give and take g off the gry was
way g off the gry was way cooler
though could have done to save
Middle Earth dude he was a what are you
how would St that he stud dude
dude he killed that dumbass
Wizard and then took his
robe no dude he looks way cooler in the
gray robes than in the white one I think
it's complicated anyway let's move on
lot right now so you guys can go ahead
and just pick whoever you want to go
first but we'll go person by person and
then you can show us the three rocks
each person Pi let's just start okay
let's start going this way from here
this way yeah
so we have AB right here this one was
you want to hold the mic and I'll do the
reveal sure so here we go this
is who picked this one AB so these are
all these next three are ABS right all
right let's take a look oo here we go oh
it's sanite we saw this it's sanite it's
sarapan knite people it's a sarff and
wrap cuz it's call a day damn uh what
would you value that one at
I'll it a buck 50 what what would you
all value that one at the sarapan this
is a cool piece I mean it's really
pretty you could like at 20 bucks Zero
Bar no well let's say 20 20 bucks 20
bucks sure all right so A's got 20 nice
a might early Jade here too CU it would
have been tumbled away is if fit on the
outside yeah a lot of them have like
Jade inclusions the thing is I sent uh
Dan a little diagram about how a lot of
these rocks are they have like the same
minerals in them uh but they're called
different things and so these are kind
of an amalgamation of a bunch of
different rocks like Serpentine
antigorite uh quartz and Jade and
nefrite a whole bunch of stuff um that
the one we already saw that second one
we saw outside already yeah this one was
amazonite so I guess the main question
is this if I was doing Jade gambling in
the beautiful province of Yun
junin would this rock would that first
rock be a winner they would throw this
in the trash so hard yeah not really
hell that's a trash rock they dunk this
kind of garbage all right so what's next
for
ab oh these ones so we already saw this
one outside so I'm going to do the one
that you didn't see this is a beautiful
green one wow gorgeous and I mean it's
look my God it's amazonite amazonite
beautiful it's gorgeous so what is the
difference what is
amazonite Felts bar it's like
right
yeah actually his favorite
Stone so that's an L that's trash rock
right yeah unfortun but still Let's uh
let's put a value on all of these so we
can keep track so these would probably
go for like say Jade gambling I mean
it's $10 right here $10 she okay but
again if you're Jade Gambler and you
trash trash you throw in the garbage
doesn't even have any kind of Jade in it
spear I see a lot of Amazon Spears yeah
no people like them like 20 bucks so
trash but that's if it's a sphere we're
saying zero for that then if it's going
in the trash if if I'm a jade Gambler
for the sake of Jade zero and I'm I'm
throwing that in the trash then it's a
zero we're doing on a jade scale now so
zero zero okay all right here we go the
third and final one that's also sanite
sanite oh this was the one that we
previewed outside this one's probably
$10 cuz site is cool and if you're a j
and if you're a jade
Gambler
uh they're going to run it over with
their car just for fun okay so so just
to be clear are are we're we're not
counting the value of them unless it's
like a a jade or Jade adjacent there's
like the California cost and like uh Val
value and then there's the China value
so we'll go by China value this is
listen the point of this exercise is to
role play as as Jade gamblers so and as
such it's a trash rock and it's a trash
rock so we're not going to do monetary
value we're just going to go does it get
comes to the J accepted or is it trash
so unfortunately these ones would be
thrown in the garbage maybe you got a
big F zero here it sounds maybe there is
a type of stone that they would want to
keep I don't know m
okay it's like this California stuff is
also more rare to them too so like it's
hard to say but for the sake of the game
garbage garbage garbage so AB failed to
acquire struck
out this right here is Dan okay here we
go we got Big Winners coming up
now these ones are a little dark so you
want to hold this this is Dan's first
rock very dark
baby beautiful inside but
Serpentine garage serpe stupid Stone
looks great I mean it's
beautiful is the inside smooth or coarse
they're always pretty smooth they have
like oh that's so interesting patterns
it looks super smooth but I don't know
you guys just saw it open so I don't
know that's it's also wet me get
the serpentine out of here I don't
even want to see it slithering ass Rock
disgusting next one for Dan another dark
I need to I need to pay rent I put all
my rent money come on baby show us Jade
Serpentine Serpentine again Dam there's
a little bit of Jade in there but very
very few tiny bit little tiny bit they
would they would still throw it away
that's a they're throwing it away then
well this is unin this the one that Dan
cut open outside but I'll give it a re
Dan Third Rock which has some beautiful
coloration on the
outside oh ovite which is a valuable
stone actually Green Garnet only two
sources in the world that's one of the
on WE this is some bright green Garnet
on the outside you've got uh streams of
it and it's in Serpentine which is a
cool thing so you think this might be a
valuable stone you know even to someone
in China who can't get this this would
be valuable this is interesting so what
do we what do we value that rock at so
you can see a little bit of ovite on the
outside the inside is not as green as
you would want it to be but I could
still say like $20 $20 $20 y W
congratulations big
[Applause]
money congratulations Dan on the board
guy we cut what was the name of that
stone again just not a lot this one
isite roite
yite
dude Dan Dan Abby can you come up here
for a sec please Dan I can come collect
it uh yes and you could come assist me
please he was riding the this camera's
getting a little heavy if you just hold
this oh yeah thank you AB was holding
the he's doing it now we have Sam he
doesn't get paid to do
both so this is Sam so Dan so we're done
with Dan D Dan I had $20
Rock very good all right here's Sam who
is Sam this
is beautiful oh it has Jade lots of Jade
in there there's Jade in there that's
Jade Jade hold on I got to get a close
look at this it's Jade inside of of
white quartz there's Jade on the outside
very visibly there's Jade all throughout
here which parts the Jade so that
darkest Jade you could see the green a
lot better in the
sunlight let it looks it looks dark
though oh right now Jade the
house all that Jade a lot of California
Jade is very dark like there's a lot of
black jade in California did it talk to
like spoke to me I just knew it
whispered sweet nothing from the water
we all talking at the same time my are
your girl Olivia Sam yeah we are yeah
stop stop
talking stop stop talking please got it
got it got it peace and love I'm sorry I
just people talking look in that light
you can see the green a lot better the
the blue tongue lighting just it looks
black to me how can you tell it J and
look at this lighting sunlight you'll
see the green well California has a lot
of black jade
how can you tell it's Jade just where it
comes from just how hard it was to cut
okay wow got those
eyes I knew because of the way that it
is yeah yeah so I'm keeping track of uh
the value how much would you value that
that right now I got another one would
be the value of that oh yeah okay what
would you say so it's very small Jade it
is doesn't glow um but it is kind of a
lot in there sandwich between would you
say this is all quartz yeah I think so
um outside's got a lot of really pretty
Jade on it too $30 do a whole lot yeah
cuz you can't do a whole lot with that
did you say $30 I would say $303 $30 it
would make it would make some good cabs
but there's not be awesome there's not a
whole lot you can do about isolating the
Jade itself so you have a would really
show it off though so this would still
make some cool jewelry C would look
great so is that was that first stone
you got five or six cabachons out of
this to sell them all separately so
let's check in on Sam's next Stone here
yeah can I ask you a question when you
cut it open does it lose its value or no
no it gains value these all gained a
little bit of value as I cut them when
you cut it op because people know what
they're getting got it so here's Sam's
second Stone it is blue
appetite not Jade but an awesome Stone
um beautiful stone I mean it's one of
the BL are we keeping it or are we
throwing it into the over we're saying
words like awesome and beautiful what
about
valuable uh yeah no it's trash Z trash
not really trash those are being thrown
angr towards a trash can
Trash Trash all right so mean to the
stones I'm not used to this I know was
like bullying okay this last one from
Sam third Stone from Sam o Jade Jade
double Jade your Jade double
Jade that one looks crazy oh it glows
that's a lot of glow for California if
it glows at all really for California
yeah really good Sam th yeah it's a
really good one I'm rich look at that
that's pure
jade look at that glow look at that
that's one of the better pieces
California is this all Jade any the dark
stuff you see is all Jade and what's the
green stuff that's serpentinite or
Serpentine but Serpentine is what turns
into Jade so it's like half baked I see
I see it's not quite done cooking but
it's really getting there and how many
years are we talking before this is all
Jade be quite a few quite a few more
than uh you know more than two two
million more than two probably a couple
thousand couple of million cou a couple
thousand that's not
bad wow
Samantha wait so how much was that I me
that look at that glow so what was the
value yeah what would we value that one
at this one I don't like
$100 it's pretty good it's a it's a
really solid green there's not a whole
lot of impurities in it that's a high
pitch tin dude do you guys remember
cutting that one open was it hard I I'm
going to tell immediately What It Is by
how hard it's cutting Sam you're at 130
what can I say I know Myck rocks I know
my rocks I swear I I saw it all right
this is like why I'm agnostic about it
cuz I'm like who knows so is that Sam's
last rock or did she have one more still
that was that was all of cly winning so
far let's should we close it cuz it's
done I'm very impressed with Sam who
pulled what can only be described as a
gorgeous beautiful J Stone my goodness
well done well done next up wow wow it
is actually quite it is beautiful Sam
I'm as
crap
okay so I'm up next this is of course uh
this was the casualty from the dumpster
throw we retrieved it don't worry oh
yeah you retrieved it you didn't
have to do that you guys went in the
dumpster for those this is chry of
Praise like
someone it's
pretty so it was really hard to cut cuz
chrys of Praise is a good stone that
would probably even have like in China
they would still pay $1 $20 for the
stone so so is it 10 or 20 15 yeah we'll
go with that 15 okay I like that I asked
you to help me with pricing with my Etsy
shop every day so I got please just let
me have one Jade stone oh and then the
other one otherwise I'm going to be a
[Music]
joke green adventuring that's beautiful
it is a quartz based Stone very pretty
probably worth nothing it's quartz and
green M dude the the glow test cuz it's
quartz with green M it's just green I
was misled with the glow cuz they don't
glow here apparently only in China do
they glow interesting it's still so at
one point they glowed but the the
crackhead of Jade Cove got to them first
we're at we're all picking through
leftovers that green adventuring is like
the most commonly mistaken for Jade it
is it's the most common a lot and so
what what's not good about that stone
it's just fragile oh it's it's noong
it's a six on a hardness scale out of 10
and Jade is a sevens what's its hardness
six out of 10 J it's not as hard but
it's still pretty hard yeah you said
people mistake it for Jade do people
ever sell it counterfeit for Jade yes so
maybe it is worth something we could
sell it illegally on the black market
Black Market you could do that m i mean
with the color in the glow Black Market
,000 anything is possible when you lie
right that's true this is if this was
pure Jade if this was California pure
Jade this would be $1,000 piece wow with
that glow
but actually this not in in this economy
why is that one worthless just cuz it's
more common yeah quartz is more common
than any other mineral on the world it
is the most So when you buy a piece of
quartz all right don't rub it in it's
pretty but it's
worthless all right all right we have
the last one please please I
need Jade please don't do this broke so
this one took forever to cut we were not
anticip this one got decimated just give
up on that hear that it took forever to
cut boom
plasma agot plasma agot from Clear Creek
California this is a this green in here
is a agatized chac cola what's plasma
about it look at it just like the plasma
e shape I should cut it the other
direction it would have had a better so
you might have if you got this rock out
a jade gambling uh what would you do
with it so like I mentioned earlier uh I
can send a plasma aot to China and have
them process it for free if I let them
have some because they can't get it and
it is very sought-after okay plasma aot
is comes from one place in the world and
that is uh Central California and the
place was the road
was down for like it was washed out and
it just opened up recently after a
really long time too so after the storm
it's probably a lot of good stuff to
look so it's one of those things where
it's kind of hard to get to as well
which also UPS the value no it's easy to
get to the runoff pieces there's a mine
that's hard to get to but if you go to
the Clear Creek
Campground uh in the creek if you walk
around you'll find uvarovite you'll find
plasma agot you'll find I found nefrite
there I found jadeite there and
Serpentine um you want to go after it
rains how much am I making here what
what's the deal with the plasma is it
more or less valuable than my blood
plasma you know bet you have nothing I
see cabash for these selling for $90 in
a cab actually agree cuz yeah Chris made
some cabachons out of plasma it $300
those guys are like $300 that's worth
300 it it took longer to cut than Jade
what yo it's really
rare jackpot bro when you cut it
right those dark bits are very uh
transparent and they would glow if you
Pol you had it like isolated so if if
there's a piece I have at home that's if
you guys I'm going to leave the Rock
With You obviously it's your stuff but
you do something with it I get them for
free and they're I can go get $1,000
more tonight if I want like it's free to
get it's just rocks you just have to go
get it you just have to go get it but
would you do something with that rock or
no Pro I they these have some of these
have been sitting in my yard for a year
two years some three so not much I think
this one I've had for three years we
want to do something with them probably
are we going to we might be too busy
that's the thing would you sell it would
you attempt to send it off to China uh
the ones that I sent to China are
Boulders like this big oh they're bigger
yeah that's be expensive as well
maybe if you mention that it was Ethan's
rock you might be able to do something
with it saying is like any of these now
are completely uh different and valuable
man I didn't get any Jade but I did get
plasma it's a really cool Stone to have
and it's more rare than Jade and
actually like when you think about it on
a Mas it's only in Clear Creek there's a
very small amount of it it comes from
one place Jade comes everywhere you can
get Jade anywhere Jade is one of the
those stones they've scammed you into
liking okay interesting but again
there's nothing inherently valuable
about minerals right but so in a sense I
think maybe there was something in me
that CH that attracted me to that one
that I felt there's a rarity and a value
here you just must have been a really
good person in your past life I don't
know that's that's possible that makes
sense to me all right this one was
really fun to see chosen this is Cam's
he chose this big one everyone was like
why did you pick that this is new Jade
this is a winner what the it's called
banite and its trade name is being
marketed as new Jade but is it not
Jade it was really soft to cut it's not
Jade 2.0 exactly it's kind of new Jade
City it's like jadish it looks beautiful
let me take a look at that Jade adjacent
it's Jade adjacent now I don't really
know much about this I can't really tell
you much probably like $10,000 then I'm
going to put down 10,000
could you put a value on it it's
gorgeous c b you could just Google bow I
on Etsy and then get a number
immediately but say $50 million I just
Googled
$404 I'll take it uh I'm hearing $40 cam
$40 million okay no just just uh 4 Z up
z00 okay got it very good this one we
cut three cam second Rock wondering if
the pattern would
change this way so this one is fun
because already on the outside there was
this is the one that I showed Dan in the
video with the little nodule of green
right there the first thing I picked up
when I went to Jane Cove green and so I
was very excited to cut it open hold
this well let's see
inside ah you can't see on camera but
along these seams there's Jade whoa oh
you have seam Jade seams seams of Jade
seams are not worth a lot but this not
worth a lot
is it worth anything though would you
throw it in the trash would you TR China
they would value this as zero and throw
it in the trash
trash man got one more all right cam
we're rooting for
you Cam's Third
Rock This is Jade oh it's
Serpentine beautiful it's a pretty piece
we keep getting snaked oh nice for some
of called lot of these would sell really
yeah okay so all right I'll take the new
Jade cam yeah congrats on the new Jade
it is beautiful how much was the new
Jade valued at 40 I I got a graphic
going so I'll uh do the reveal at the
end all right who's next Olivia Olivia
we've all we've been talking about
Olivia the entire time literally Olivia
is so
nervous okay here we go ready that one
looks promising what is you forgot what
would this is harder than Serpentine
site no seraphite is really soft this
ising serpent Tonite okay
this is serenite which is the one stage
before Jade so almost you're so a few
thousand years off almost j0 in ch but
beautiful is that really it pretty few
it's probably a really long time it
depends on like it depends on the
pressure and the temperature and where
it's located the only one that takes
like really fast is
salinite Hite crystals too cuz it's
literally just
salt very interesting this is the second
piece from Olivia
this is Olivia
second Serpentine damn that Serpentine
man embarrassed so far the
serpent God okay rer all right whatever
his name was last piece last piece from
Olivia pure Jade through and through the
best piece that we
have no way hold on I got to see
this this is pure Jade it's pure
California Jade what oh my God as much
as you want it to but that's just
California Jade for you and so do the
Chinese love California Jade I would
think so because locality means a lot
and there's not a lot in
California like Canada Jade wouldn't
really it doesn't anything the edges
glow which is actually more than almost
all the stones do it's the density of
the stone in the color let me see this
one so it's so hard to tell you know but
the light California Jade is very very
dense we different around here we we
just grow Jade differently it's just CU
Jade eyes like Serpentine more so than
like I'm noticing California has a lot
of
serpentine right I'm I'm I'm noticing
that maybe it's more or less more a
crystalline quartz mix in there that's
why it's a little bit
cloudier
it's don't know why it's Cloud that is
like the most the most this is the
[Applause]
side there's no anything else it's just
been worn Away by the ocean tumbled
already for you tumbled pre Tumbl how
Val to put this one at
like what's the value we're crunching
the numbers we're thinking this is
beautiful pure it's pure but it's small
small and we're going by unon standard
you could make a ring not a lot of
carrots you could make some cows not a
lot of carrots not a lot of carrots no
car
it's the best quality piece we have but
it's so small so i' would say $60 $60 I
was going to say 50 50 something I was
going to say dinner on me
but dinner on you dinner for one I mean
at 50 bucks dinner for Uno I could
purest piece of Jade we have very good
it's a good winner it's just small
that's all that's the
one I'm sort of starting to believe the
Vibes thing now if Olivia got the purest
one something to it okay
um so up next who who who are these I
know which one's L these are they're
kind of these three are Lena right here
we'll do Lena
first I know what that is right uh-huh
every kid's favorite Rock hell yeah it
is I had High Hopes through this I feel
this flashlight got darker maybe it's
dying
well let's crack it open let's see what
what's inside we saw it GL earlier here
we go it's a
geod that's awesome yeah it is awesome
yeah this is a cool Stone even in China
like $5 you know everyone buy a geod
five it's something you're on the board
that looks so cool all right the second
piece so that's the first one is a
beautiful geode second one interesting
texture interesting color let's crack
this baby open ovite and Serpentine
another really cool one Serpentine man
talk about inv and ovite but that's
Green Garnet in there a rare form of
garnet uh inside of serpentine which
makes it I would put this one at $60
60 go holy one place in the world
to get it where would you sell this
stuff Etsy Etsy eBay Crystal uh trade it
at the Super Show psite Gem Show yeah
psite gem show is there a lot of people
buying this kind of stuff would it be
easy to
sell uh it depends I mean like when I
make Tik toks about it they sell really
fast so it's there's a lot of it
available so it's just kind of a
competition prices are just determined
by whoever wants it like right this is a
little one from Lena here's uh Lena's
third one boom we got a really cool tiny
geode it was in a I
got get a better view on supposed to be
carelian but there's only a little bit
of
which is really cool that's actually
kind of rare there's like a red uh depit
underneath the quartz and then over here
you have this really cool little circle
of agot with just uh quartz and stuff
outside what's the red part this is like
a hematite pocket or Carnelian a
Carnelian carelian is just hematite it's
one of my favorite Pokemon carel so so
in Union what would they
say it's cute it's it's but it's like a
dollar yeah I was GNA it's really a
dollar forget about it it's cute though
it's cute trash cute trash just like
me um um yeah up next we
have all right Ian so this is Ian all
right Ian Ian picked quickly Ian if you
guys recall he just picked him right out
Bo boom boom which I think was the the
best way to go for some re the best way
to go she says so you can see a lot
color on the
outside plasma aot but an even nicer
piece than yours but smaller plasma agot
that's the one I had it
Y where the little go right there that
one's real very valuable I think yeah so
you got a
glow good look at that green glow right
there that you polish it right up you
would have uh like three or four $90
cabasa M so 3 * 90
270 like 300 bucks
270 however I put like 250 how much was
mine worth like 300ish
$300 what the f processed processed all
right Jordan I mean damn I didn't know
he was a stone Enthusiast okay that's
good that's really good that's huge fell
I lost on with that one we have another
one that plasma dude it's valuable oh I
wonder what this one could be that's a
lemon for sure yeah that's though how
sad
they're beautiful but under appreciated
it's prettier than Jade because it's
sparkly but it's worthless cuz it's
everywhere in the world and
cheap they're such cool Stones third one
this is the third one from Ian Ian's
third Stone let's crack it open exced to
show this one
because poga Jade I knew it what is it
poga Jade from PGA County poga County
California oh po PGA Jade it's white
Jade Ethan yeah let me see oh look
at the glow that one glows very
well
mhm oh my god look jadeite this is
vesuvianite Ido craze white Jade all the
best this is all pure good Stone right
here this seems like a good pck this is
this is like a $100 piece at
least yep do it and it's is the white or
the green jade or it's all Jade it's all
Jade you just got a cool all Jade
brother wow I see it this one clows the
most I mean look at this who could have
guessed Sam and I are getting brisket
tonight 150 she just upped the appraisal
it's 150 150 it's just the color cuz a
lot of hga Jade is white but when you
have this cool coloration it uh
definitely UPS the value oh my goodness
and from the back that's a big deal W
true it's getting a light reach
around yeah this I would say this is one
of the top winners if not uh tied with
Olivia wow that is a beautiful stone
there Ian pick that random only Vibe and
you were the last to pick too
interesting all Vibes all I can
tell thank you wow very exciting all
right next we have we have Zach Zach
Zachariah come on baby Serpentine you
got hor
Serpentine is like the Buster
called
that's like
trash we hate Serpentine here on the a
podast really cool piece with what was
this sanite sanite sanite yes it looks
like green cenite it's so cool it really
does this is just right here like you're
looking yeah don't
breathe Z second Rock here it is Boom
dog hold
on hold the phone tin anything in Jaden
there but it's all this mostly it's
mostly Sur for but we have one last
piece from sorry Z Zack and it's just my
luck dude first Halloween now serpent
yeah now I get coal for
Christmas dude
this one was really dense thir was
uh they say it's dense Zach they're
clicking it what's below we're getting
clicks serpent Tonite serpent I think
this is between serpent Tonite and Jade
or
jadeite potenti Jade Z or crunching the
it was you can see how much I struggled
to cut it I would put this at J very
very
mixed so it's not one pure substance
you're un what do you do of oh you throw
it
away yeah it's trash dude that's my
luck sorry Zach man I know it's been a
hard weekend for you it's been a hard
week they would hate that I was rooting
for you man we have love over here all
right last one is love I'm really
curious about loves cuz he went for the
big boys which I thought was a good
strategy I don't know I'm not too sure
any so this one is the light on
it here we
go really good uvarovite this is the
color you want to see in the streams in
uvarovite this is in chromite uh you got
I mean this this is just Green Garnet
streams uh you got Green Garnet on the
whole outside this is really colorful
piece this could be
$200
what
$200 d
[Applause]
wait hold on can I dude I feel like you
guys could make a lot of money if you
like had a good system of just taking
the rocks out I guess you got to find
buyers maybe that's I do a lot of this
for fun and I have a really expensive
Stone like this I'll throw it up because
it's like maybe worth my time but um I
mean like just the gas to get across I
do mostly wholesale right now right but
I do I have a lot of stuff that I what's
the most you my box is the most you'll
find my single one
yeah sold uh like a $400 mystery box
once a mystery box that's my what I do
best with because I have been nwor for
years so I have really really good
mystery boxes you get so much for the
price that you pay go in blind and do
you you stack it based on the value or
yeah yeah pretty much yeah okay okay
it's the most bang for your book cuz I
it's just I both for a while I was just
selling individual crystals and then the
mystery box hit really well just like
did really good so for two years I just
did uh networking and built kind of a
business around a whole model around
just the mystery box so I would find uh
mine owners tell directly so I wouldn't
have a middleman so I could basically
buy things for the cheapest you can
possibly get um like the cheapest wow uh
and that's basically why they're and so
are is your business coming from Tik Tok
a lot of it yeah um but Etsy Marketplace
supplies a lot of foot traffic so is
this your this is your job basically
this is my fulltime job oh wow so you
are a professional Stones man no Stones
lady rockhound rockhound rockhound
that's what they're called oh really
people that go around looking for places
to mine are called Rock hounds huh
you're sniffing it out you're sniffing
some claim jumping too very cool they
still have claims how is business as a
rock seller you know it's up and down
but rocks will never stop selling I mean
a lot of the people that I meet and that
I get my locations with or work with are
from the 70s 60s been doing this uh for
50 years now and they were just as
popular then as they were now and they
have the Tucson gem show the Quartzsite
Gem Show which has been going since like
the 70s and 60s and um a lot of people
there have been do they're all listen I
when I moved into my van and started
doing this um I went straight to Arizona
for two years and I just mind and mind
and mind and then I built a uh up just
until I was able to do wholesale then uh
I because I didn't have rent in a van so
I'm just saving up for two years and
then I bought a little bit of land up
north and now I'm I have a farm but uh
my Creek has rose quartz in it and it's
just like so crazy and lots of Micah so
much crystals just pop out of my Creek
and so I went up the hill and there was
a deposit for Rose quarts and Smoky
quarts and like Micah and talene and so
they're so common you just go on a hike
like most California beaches you find
aot you'll find like Moonstone the thing
is you just have to look for it you'll
find it if you look mind at like anybody
who wants get.org
mind baby not mind will tell you or also
gem Trail books but go to antique stores
not antique antique book stores used
bookstores try and find vintage uh gem
Trail books because these old rock
hounds know a lot more than the ones
today I have these books that are from
like 2009 and it has a quarter of the
location that my book from the 70s has
so like if you want free treasure M cool
what a cool world you got literally
treft Minecraft IRL yeah you might say
you're in little un new UN I drive my
van to Bar Stow uh every couple of
months to load it up with hundreds of
pounds of red jasper so I can take it
home and process it into walkways I want
to make like a bathtub I am Ain to
Tunnel lady we are both you okay
interesting are you are you cataloging
this on your Tik Tok so people can
follow yeah I film everything I do I
film everything that I do I just haven't
posted in a while I've been it's in the
description of the episode by the way if
anybody wants to check her out I dig
crystals just like that nothing else oh
it's called I dig crystals dude that's
awesome wait hold on I'm going to open
your page that's such a good name I've
been focusing on moving in for the last
like 3 six months so if you scroll down
a little bit it's a lot of rock content
let's see I dig crystals this is co me
too girl
oh this is Instagram on Tik Tok well
it's both now you all got to buy rock
tumblers well Instagram is your main
mover Instagram is my main or I mean Tik
Tok is my main I don't post on Instagram
at all I don't use Tik Tok ever 5
million dude you're a Bonafide
Rock
Queen wait what the hell my dog's more
famous than me though dude that's
awesome hold the phone here this one has
10 million oh this is about chocolate
chocolate I I have ideas I feel will do
well and I do them and they do well but
they don't have anything to do with me
so wait which one should I watch oll
down scroll down this is The Rock area
it gets more Rock You Go free crystals
one this has million 3.5 I hide crystals
in public a lot the sunset Crystal
mining one which one oh Sunset Crystal
mining it's one of the pinned videos go
oh okay that one right there yeah this
one here yes okay great Sunset Crystal
mining Count Me In we just
coincidentally parked next to a giant
pile of cryst
kind
of I will be sharing this location at
the end of the video as soon as we
stepped out of the car there were
Crystal oh I could barely hear it
it's so
quiet okay cool literally everywhere I
noticed there were more crystals near
washes and in bushes and the closer we
got to the
mountain so basically you guys went out
to this is Saddleback Mountain this is
just on the way to Phoenix likely if
you're going on a road trip you're going
to going to drive past crystals like if
you have heard of Oatman that was like a
family spot we would go to in Arizona
I've been going there my whole life and
there I love Arizona every time you play
that sound fite I'm like me this is for
me then there's a fire aot mining like
just off the side of the road and
there's this old man who owns the land
and if you give him like 10 20 bucks
he'll give you a bucket and you just go
out crazy and if you don't find anything
he gives you a whole bunch so this is I
dig crystals on Tik Tok and then do you
guys have social media I do um I I use
Instagram mostly my uh Tik Tok is aara
aera and so is my Instagram behind um my
main business when I'm not managing the
crystal shop is I uh do like small
Oddities and Taxidermy and like preserve
specimens a little bit small scale so
that's azara's Oddities oh Oddities
that's awesome my resent goth friend
real hold on I'm opening your Instagram
look at that one do you have a social
media you want to you want
to I don't really post at all but we
kind of just share Tik Tok you're in all
of my Tik toks but yeah I post Rock
mining locations in California and other
random really random cool so this
is a is this like a that's just my like
my page where I just post like makeup
and makeup and outfits and costumes and
stuff I don't have any science here's
crystals in the background I don't have
any science on my main page it's on my
Oddities page got it oh wait where's
your a okay's Oddities oh the a pretty
she is so which one do you want us to
add that that one or this one uh this is
my money yeah do I want cloud or money
use this
one yeah cuz it's it's in there there
you
go there we got little
coffins little with the stuff in them
we're so bomb thank you buy her buy her
stuff buy it buy it buy it creepy
consume cons very good I dig crystals
man I sure do I got to follow you I sold
those ones in that video sometimes I
make a video people will be like where
can I buy that so I will list them a lot
oh there you go I'm I'm going to follow
you there there's more right um yes just
the rest of right we kind of got
distracted let's uh let's finish up love
here all right so we did that one I'm
glad we kind of built a little bit of
anticipation
we got some we got some fun ones okay
producers all right this
will here we go another big Ro concerned
cuz this section was here it was flat
and it broke apart as I was cutting it
but that was just a layer of serpentine
around Jade no way Jade Center you got
black
jade dark pretty dark GRE that whole ass
big ass Stone this low but this is some
cool Jade oh my goodness holy got
you got to throw this one a tumbler
it'll shave away oh yeah you polish that
one so pretty but the stuff around it is
really soft so um the reason why we knew
Olivia was really well was because there
was it was Jade through and through
which means that it has been tumbled for
a long time uh so anything that was not
Jade came off so it was just a pure
nodule of Jade and this one you throw in
a tumbler you're just going to it's all
the outside's going to wear away you're
going to have this big cool piece of
Jade dude I'm going to be T shoke you
should come do it these would be Cool's
all right and then the last one is the
biggest
we yes okay um it's a weird shape and
the color is dark but it's a big Stone
it's a big Stone weird and dark
$30 30 30 30 bucks between 30 and
50 this way if you're you're jesman and
unun what do you do with it you tumble
it yeah you can can tumble it and then
carve it into one of those cool little
scenes or things that they do so let's
say let's say like 40 45 I don't know
it's big but the color is not preferable
so the size helps a lot so a 30 40 okay
very good congrats thank you thank you
sir right the big I was so happy when
you picked cuz I this one big boy here
it's going to be it took so long to cut
that we could cut all the way through so
I had to come in through the side
that's a good sign holy smokes they
couldn't cut they had to cut pure
jadeite all the way
through no say it ain't so dude Jade
stronger than Jade I to stronger than
Jade
God hardness scale no there are little
bits of clear Jade in there that do glow
seven and a half probably seven and a no
this is more closer to seven or eight I
mean you said seven he literally said
seven and a
half um see I wouldn't expect this yeah
no it it's not all Jade is like
transparent that's the thing it's so
dense super
heavy so this is a whole this is a big
rock so I imagine this gu to be valuable
I have some a rock even bigger than that
that's pure Jade in my car feel how
heavy that
is that's a big boy that's a big boy oh
gosh okay oh man you can make a lot with
this Stone oh shoot oh love love piece
there's two pieces these two yeah soar
would you say two or 300
no I'm bad at making the P go ahead it's
up here ji go ahead I'd say 300 300
300 $300
$300 it really doesn't have like a whole
lot of impurities it's it's really solid
wow that is like solid J R holy
dude that's solid J what a hle d now I
got to fly to a a country or a state
that has Jade that glows oh those Jade
nodules in the creek so I can just do
boop boop boop boop cuz that's a fun way
to look for Jade is when the ones glow
and like everything's holy it's
past 5 Jesus Christ we're having fun in
the Jade we're having way too much fun
out here got it all I'm going to youa
yeah and then we have gift too but this
was a what the
I30
something jle I was going to say we were
in a jade well we would really like to
give gifts on air but if there's not
enough time no we have time so okay we
done with all the stones so that's all
that's everyone so hold on let's let's
take a look at the leaderboard here oh
yeah who's the big
winner I came in pretty nice Chris Chris
St christop find this is so cool plasma
aate a aot aot just you know the slur
without yeah what you call me love is
crushing it with a
monster wait that's a lot of money I
knew it dude I'm fly to that is a lot of
money Sam coming in at
130 Ian coming clean with 400 freaking
bucks dude Zach and ab the only ones
with zero Zach that's so Zack but we we
want the best for
that we want the best M don't you want
to get your anger out with the really
bad pieces you got
yeah have had it just start chucking
them you trash cans we get some shots
from outside throwing them I would but I
think we're just yeah just want to get
on with it but um Love is the clear
winner here and not only that cuz I came
in with this plasma a a aot
aot just let him say a but you got J you
won J Love A that's the dream a yeah I
got some pure as J
dude that's hug great birthday
give for love man that's true that's
true that's true thank you guys and so
uh I understand you brought gifts that
you wanted to present yes yes very good
very good thank you guys I already gave
Ela her she said she had meetings to go
to this one's for ELA which I'll it's a
this one's for you oh sliced Bubbies I
grew up on Bubbies so you understand
nobody knew nobody I tell my friends
like try Bubbies and they're like why is
it I don't care wait I've never seen bu
on their pickled green tomatoes which
are like the best thing in the world but
then they stopped making them it was my
whole childhood okay wait but they say
you can pickle green tomatoes with the
brine this is bread and butter pickle
that means they're sweet right I don't
know about pickles
all right hold on and to be fair my Ral
was out of the other one so I just sawes
and was like I don't think I've
never had these so let's let's just get
I don't think I got these but I trust
bues with my life that's true I mean
it'd be hard to expect anything but the
best that's kind of like the Jade of
fruits it is okay so they had pickled
green tomatoes when I was a kid that
were stellar and the website says that
they can't get a source that's regular
anymore and so if you want to recreate
them you take the brine from the normal
Bubbies and just put it on green
tomatoes and you can pickle them huh
it's I also wanted to get you my
favorite luxury chocolate in the world
it's in Beverly Hills down the street
not down the street it's really far away
Beverly Hills is like the other side of
La same yeah uh and Sons febles
Hershey's all of it don't even
go to ladak don't go to any other luxury
chocolate they are scamming you so wait
do you have that chocolate I didn't have
time to go cuz we hit
we I'll tell you why we couldn't go when
we get to Love's gift I'm kidding this
is beautiful thank you but for the love
of God Ethan you have to try and Sons
chocolate and and Suns and Suns I just
how do how's it spelled I every and Sons
just just and and then Sons it's a very
B whoever and the sons of just and Sons
and Sons chocolate it's the video I did
that got 10 million
views they were the $60 chocolate option
which was the cuz it was the best
chocolate I've ever had and I am a
chocolate simier I love luxury chocolate
do you have a finer sense for stone or
chocolate would you say I would say
chocolate everyone showed and choc
everyone I've showed chocolate has
Brothers anywhere else I have a friend
who every time she comes to La makes me
take her there and she brings home
chocolate because she can't eat her
chocolate at home anymore going so good
Friday we'll we'll get some of that my
chocolate videos I've made two different
chocolate uh cuz I saw like a good
mythical B doing price comparison videos
and I knew that would do good I did
chocolate 10 million views did another
one 5 million views uh because I call
them truffles but apparently you can't
call a truffle a truffle unless you're
from America I guess cuz truffles are
like soft chocolate dipped in cocoa
powder but we go to Seas candies and we
get a truffle which is just chocolate
with anything on the inside but all of
my comments were people Furious me
they're like that's not truffle truff
are soft chocolate dipped in cocoa
powder so I'm here to sayles lab
truffles are truffles just like ji you
know and okay we'll move on okay a we
have we have stuff for everybody so
should I just like I'll just let's do
them rapid fire all
right this is a selenite Tower oh
beautiful this is a selenite Tower and
it's a candle holder so itow you put a
candle in it why did AB get and was
there an explanation or
oh a GL wait shiny it's very shiny yeah
you put a
candle that like magic when you turn it
it gets so bright there a
connection nice it is like magic that's
beautiful it looks like it's turning on
and off doesn't it it's very flashy like
picture glitch
yeah very nice baby what a beautiful
present for a beautiful man for cam we
have one for cam that's all right Cam
Cameron we got cam Snow White
you know uh there's a lot of controversy
over the new Snow White it was actually
cam cast as midle cam we got you the
parrot do you want to come collect or
yeah do I go up there okay yeah hold on
I mean well maybe we're you can come get
it or we can just leave it on the table
for you power through him yeah well
yeah yeah he's already here we have this
and and and is that card from Stone what
is the bird wait there's more card from
multiple different crystals oh wow the
beautiful no I got it I got it okay
stonebird and a bird SK oh it broke on
the way here I'll give you it's an
amethyst bird skull amethyst is tough
that one shouldn't have
broken Cameron says thank you thank you
thank you jungle as much as we can
there's a beautiful purple stone there
so this is for uh this is for Dan oh
it's in a baggie um it's in a bag I know
what this is the three of them um
they're worry stones because uh Ethan's
gonna send you into an early grave with
all the doxing so not that these are
like not these are like a it's like a
fidget toy but it's a cool okay other
one a fidget stone for Dand cool Stone
worry stone yeah got tiger's eye
beautiful Dan is coming up to collect
his Stones absolutely gorgeous can you
guys tell me in the Jade videos they
sometimes give them like a little
Medallion of stone do you know what that
is for do you know what I'm talking
about I don't know but like a call Chris
he would just tell us everything I'm not
sure these are fun to fidget with very
good they're so smooth very
good I'm Ethan I'm a do we love Stones
today folks we are huge fans of the
stone uh as a just as a thing that when
you realize they become an activity and
not just something you put on your shelf
so for and how do the pickles glow
oh a little bit oh yeah this is dud I
love this one yerite dude my boys are
going to love this and I know they love
dinosaurs I had agot dinosaurs but I
sold out a week ago oh a dinosa egg if
you tell them it's real they'll believe
you dude he is going to is going to
freak the out oh that's cool for
your unborn child so Scotty oh that's a
beautiful it's just a really one of
those stones that kind of captivates you
as a child don't forget that was the
stone that got me into crystals other
than uh
rainbow latti Sunstone and when you look
at it close there's so much going on you
put a flashlight on it this this is not
the it's over
here wow it's so smooth and light you
got to find the
labradoresence where's the beauty angle
I see it here when it's in the sunlight
it really glows it's really colorful you
kind of see it there um wow dude dude
big boys are going to fre over these
this one's from Azara it's a little
ammonite it's
iridescence on the back and it's a
little fossil oh beautiful it's a little
amonite fossil like
fossils amazing and they are going to
love you really need this it is a gacha
and roller your face made out of Jade
please take care of your skin we're
begging you trying I'm trying you can't
just use the Jade to heal it you have to
apply something with the Jade how do I
open it
aqu it you know maybe we should have
open oh wait no it opens here okay I see
it's not a push it's a while you get
that open I'll go through the other ones
on there too yeah oh I think no I think
it's just the roller oh okay um Sam we
have a little rose
quartz Decor it's a little statement
piece cute the statement piece oh that's
beautiful yeah it's like a little little
guy yeah also
that my
god oh the mushroom is sick is that cut
from one piece of stone or is it oh
that's Lena also gets a jade roller oh
that's so
cool STS
Lena and Amethyst oh my gosh thank you
so much they're
beautiful and for that one off time when
Ian said that he has to be strapped down
because of his night tears I thought a
amethyst because it is known widely to
help uh calm you in sleep and help with
known for sleep aid it is like since the
Greeks they were like oh yeah this is
going to help you sleep dude that's a
thoughtful gift I've been acting up
lately so you've been having issues I've
been having a little bit lately so thank
you that's hope it helps you know what
let's see let's do a report we'll see if
it helps oh oh okay oh yeah it does
have the guacha nice so I got I got it
open so this is pure
Jade I mean that's what it said on the
box that's what it says do with this
stuff these are like weird mom tools to
me you roll it on your face bro roll
that sh the girls will show you well
this one it's for Contours and stuff
right for drainage L down drainage for
drainage it is that's what it's
for and okay and um and this one you
used to justtin roll the magic on you
use it to apply like moisturizer and
stuff for applying moisturizer I maybe
do it on your eyes oh my eyes oh yeah Oh
Donna around there looks better
already okay I see a difference
relaxing that should definitely help
with the rashes on the eyes so the
theory with these that it just feels
good and good vibes from the
Jade I mean it's like a massager yeah M
masser to apply like thank you guys I
use it to apply things and I use the
gacha with um uh like aaur or something
just like massage cuz lymphatic drainage
is the only thing with uh scientific
backing about that thing very good I
love it thank you
guys thank you guys so much this been so
fun
y so thoughtful too oh Z what this is
Zach my guy what's up dude it is pure sh
dude it's a sh
pyramid thank you very much thank you
the color
returned the 5 G is gone L get this it's
a pyramid it's a pyramid which is like
the the shape did you did you make this
no no we got it like that my right now
so funny look at that dude yo you're
never going to get Corona virus now dude
it's awesome what is that it's a pyite
ghost face oh that's although it might
be curse
Z no it prevents curse why do you got to
put that in I'm just saying it's a scary
face it's a scary face but the the shite
negates the cursed Energy creen Water
concert our last gift uh I have here for
love it's a Taco Bell gift
card let's go we couldn't find that's so
funny that's beautiful wow yeah come up
and get your friese love hell yeah I
feel like you know when you're like in
elementary school and they do like you
do like a runathon participation and
then people get like a prize and they
walk up that's love right now Donna's
birthday a look at that it's a butterfly
it is just little bowl for putting rings
in a rainbow or a rainbow rbow well this
is so nice she's going to love this also
I found this piece of serpentine that
looks exactly like a guitar pick and so
I filed off the tip a little bit I want
to know I want to
know we have a serpentine oh my
God holy it's nearly
J
[Music]
oh
I